foreign
it is Monday August 14th working our way
through August and I'll tell you what
boy is it a beautiful day not raining
out here in Los Angeles cheers today out
here in Los Angeles
we're back the new week today's episode
is sponsored by gamer sups thank you to
them we love our Gamers subs don't we
folks
sure do
uh we've got a fantastic show for a
switcherooie
um
how's everybody doing
well and how are you
from the weekend to report
uh when San Francisco that's really nice
first time uh second time but uh met a
lot of Super Troopers there so really
nice yeah and
um
you drove I'm assuming yes sir that
drive sucks doesn't it so freaking long
dude it wasn't too bad the way back was
a little bit more annoying but ugh I
used to do that drive because Santa Cruz
is Right South of San Francisco
oh interesting and it was God damn I
just hated that drive it was so long
every time drive angry but I guess it's
uh I guess if you haven't done it a
million times maybe it's not so bad yeah
nice I was wondering is that where you
guys shot the Twilight Tick Tock it is
yeah it was like super cloudy uh on
Friday or was it Saturday one of the day
yeah Saturday Saturday yeah and like the
golden foggy the golden great uh Bridge
was like all fogged up so yeah we shot
that there it looked like twice it looks
so like where it's I thought you guys
like found the the spot yeah that's what
everyone was saying it's so good
yeah there it is
anything else in San Fran
uh no I don't think well it's just crazy
like everyone was telling us that
there's a lot of Smash and grabs going
on there and it was scary like we were
afraid to leave anything in the car
because we were getting a lot of tick
tock videos too while we were there of
people just smashing windows and
stealing
um but yeah that was that was it the
other thing even leave your windows open
so that people don't just smash them
yeah they're still going through a car
yeah
come on in everybody
I guess the Republicans are right
California is a hellscape
I guess there was like a DA there that
like decriminalized uh stealing anything
like under a certain amount or it was
like or it's just a misdemeanor if it
was like under a thousand dollars
something like that and it made it a lot
worse
I've seen a lot of videos of people
going into like CVS and just filling
that bag up yeah yeah there was a major
robbery 30 people in the valley uh the
Topanga mall over the weekend
yeah dude it was nuts man wait why
didn't I hear about that what happened
30 people 30 people they oh 30 people
all committed a robbery together yeah
what did they rob uh Nordstrom
Nordstrom
is there a video of it yeah I believe so
yeah that's awesome dude okay Topanga
Mall that's the mall I always go to with
my kids with my family same here I might
I'm there all the time VIP High Roller
at that point but they weren't they
weren't like packing heat or anything
they just mobbed it right I believe so
okay that's less scary it also happened
at a Century City the other week
yeah um they robbed the Gucci store
there and at Glendale uh Galleria a
bunch of people robbed I think he was
like YSL here it is
Topanga Mall Nordstrom's robberies 60 to
100 000 stolen
there used to be a California Pizza
Kitchen uh next to this Nordstrom yeah
work next to it for like five years so
it's crazy to see this
that's what anyone who lives in the
valley knows this spot
beautiful mall by the way love it there
beautiful Nordstroms as well we were
gorgeous mall we were supposed to go
over the weekend but
thank God I did it yeah I don't think
they mugged anyone yeah nothing would
happen no but still you know I mean it's
Nordstrom still recover Gucci they'll
recover
what I'm seeing is just mob style Smash
and grab robbery well here it is guys
Feast your eyes this is what California
hellscape looks like Texas let's go I'm
leaving
Jesus man oh yeah they PL how do you get
this many people together who are down
for this
is it a Facebook group or something
Nordstrom Smash and grab on August 13.
there was storm Area 51 storm Nordstrom
listen times are hard man I mean that's
all this tells me
and they got away huh
there's a lot of police in the valley
then no one
huh
oh there they are a little too late
there
what is he on his cell phone what are
you doing man get to work
now's not a time for chit chat
yeah I mean listen I
robberies like this are a symptom of uh
difficult times
so I don't really get mad at robbers
like this
yeah
I mean it's up it'd be more
up frankly if they were like
going into homes
into small businesses
still wrong
and scary
there's no victim
okay really unless you call Gucci and I
guess people got scared it's scary it's
scary it'd be scary yeah to be in there
I'd be pit I'd be scared it
wasn't my kids dude that'd suck my
sister and my mom were in a department
store when it got robbed one time with
like guns or just smashing I don't think
so I think it was just one guy who
robbed the store you don't know what's
gonna happen in there somebody ride
robbed a jewelry store at that mall when
I was working there once jeez right that
must have been armed right I think so
yeah yeah
how many years ago something's going on
at Topanga Mall y'all need to get your
together
just thankful it wasn't the latest the
part baby the LEGO store thank God they
they keep that sacred I'll tell you what
man if there's ever an armed if there's
ever an armed theft of the Lego Store
Zach you're the first suspect there you
go dude there we go he took all of our
rare Mario coins
are you crazy man
I mean I I got to assume you got to be
in a pretty bad situation to be down for
this because
if you have a good job you're not doing
this
no you're just not doing it
that's my theory anyway
you know what I mean
guys and if you disagree remember
Aladdin okay Aladdin and his monkey and
the bread they were stealing the bread
were they bad people no they were not if
you ask them the street bird should stay
ready to chop his head off right but he
had a heart of gold he did have articles
that bread
I don't buy that
that's a great movie man yes that's one
of the great ones one of the greats
Oakland State of Mind what's happening
here these are like the Smashing grips
that are going on near San Francisco
it's wild this guy's just doing it right
in front of the person
oh that's their car yeah I believe dude
just pulled over his license plate he's
got his plates out and everything yep
wow uh his gas cap is open somebody
should let him know
no sir excuse me sir sir
excuse me your gas cap maybe they stole
it from a gas station while someone's
filling up no no no he's like need help
with your bag oh forgetful yeah there's
actually another video on this page of
someone doing that dude doesn't even
know what's in the damn suitcase it's
probably just underwear and a
used dildo
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
what else is in a suitcase
clothes personal belongings yeah
valuable in a suitcase right
right if I have valuable it's on my
in my bat or my backpack right tip to
anyone who wants to mug me
good thing I barely leave my house so
chances are low
colleague gee willikers man
it's a troubled World out here
but at the end of the day there's not
enough space in prisons right like what
the f should we really be putting these
people in prison I don't know
it's all messed up
I got to assume that the D.A in San
Francisco did it because
like
the cost and the space is just not there
I don't know
yeah I think it was good intentions but
I don't know anything about it granted
so
if I'm speaking at a turn here
then I apologize it's a nice car what's
with the damn the
the suitcase
I was terrified all weekend every DM I
got was do not leave anything in the car
well San Francisco is a big city I mean
it's like
and you're from Detroit dude and you
live in Los Angeles yeah you're not
listen my brother you're fine my
brother-in-law who's from Detroit who
lives in San Fran now was like yo he
literally came outside he's like I'm
here to help you guys I don't want you
to leave anything in the car and he's
like in a super nice area like there's
like CEOs that live around him I don't
know what the hell is going on something
about watching someone move like as fast
as they can when holding something heavy
is so goofy like the way that He Flops
them into the car he's working so so
hard how did he even know there was
back there like look at that man
such a good move these guys are pretty
good at it I was slick do you think you
practiced for sure they've done that a
few times
but what could be in the luggage God
damn it my dildos
dildos no
oh that is crazy though God damn I
mean it sucks I don't I don't have a
solution hey I'm not running for
governor don't vote for me not my
problem talk to Gavin Newsom about it
I just mind my own business
all right well
this is happening
oh we already saw this
well condolences and I think only to the
to the
the people whose suitcases were stolen
that's that being said San
Francisco very beautiful place it is
very cute yeah very very very expensive
very beautiful
maybe you should try if you live in San
Francisco do do like the mark Robert
thing where they put a camera do it with
a box of dildos
that's what they're after though that's
what my brother-in-law said dildos are
pretty expensive they try to sniff good
ones yeah those costs are pretty penny
what maybe and my brother-in-law said
that that's what the cops should do they
should like plant suitcases with like
trackers in them or something like Mark
Rober or whatever but they're not
arresting him anyway that's why they
don't give a
they're straight up out there with their
license plate number right being
recorded by everybody there that's true
crazy dude
Street cat Riff Raff you don't need that
oh is that a later line I want all of
your dildos right have we got a shirt
great movie when he's swinging from
um from the fabric it's really it's a
powerful moment for me it's this
beautiful gorgeous moment wow wow
stunning when he and Abu watched the sun
rise you guys have a favorite Disney
film with their life yeah Lion King oh
okay well anyway no what is it
okay that's a good one yeah I think my
favorites Mulan
you know dude I've never seen Mulan oh
my really so good that's always like
kind of my Dark Horse answer as well
really I I underappreciate it that might
be rocks also songs are so fire music
really good amazing anime I think it
might be my favorite Disney movie okay
wow Lion King it's a good one
oh my God
the car isn't that a live action one yes
yes okay well that's talking about the I
didn't say any Disney movie ever I mean
Classics I'll give you turn around here
we have a whole chat called Turner does
the dog die I don't remember no no the
dog is everything the dogs
tell me if this is what happened Tom
Hank dies the dog is stuck stuck in the
apartment with him the dog eats his
corpse to stay alive is that what
happened that might have been the part
two which I haven't seen in prologue
that's not what happens the epilogue
first one they solve crime together
oh well that's great I love that
yeah Lion King's I mean if you want to
talk about music yeah come on forget
about it oh and in Kanto that's a new
one
so beautiful yeah it's so good and cut
Encanto
it's in Spanish that word oh I did see
that one is that the Day of the Dead one
what's the one where he's like uh but
they live in Casita Coco that's Coco
that one man up dude Coco
was sick and Kanto was good that was
that we don't talk about whatever we
don't talk about Bruno yeah yeah Olaf's
frozen adventure I guess I gotta catch
up that's a good one classic actually
y'all are not gonna like this but I
truly believe that Toy Story is one of
the most overrated Trilogy of all time
it's just not it's like good but
buy the third one it just gets really
depressing I haven't seen it yeah I
don't really care for the third one that
much but I thought the first two were
great look the first one was
revolutionary in terms of the look and
the production was that but I mean
we didn't need the trilogy we didn't
need the Buzz Lightyear spin-off either
although I did like that bro there was
four of them
yeah oh there they did make a fourth the
fourth one I have beef with that
character that made Forkey that guy's a
little piece of I hate it
what's his name Forkey
piece of trash dude what's your
problem with pork he's just a little
annoying little piece of
thing
okay Zach chill dude
piece of trash write better they could
have done something so much better Jesus
yeah I got beef with 4K dude wow don't
even get me I wasn't even aware does the
fork listen to Klein water revival or
something nah dude he's like he listens
to like like fish or some
like that
all right well anyway say that you think
Lion King has the best music of all of
them dude they all the classic ones have
amazing music I mean I'm an Elton John
fan so I love The Lion King stuff I mean
those songs are hits even people don't
even know that it's like a Lion King
song yeah oh yeah Lion Sleeps Tonight
yeah can you feel like alive you know
just can't wait to be king that song is
so good it's crazy I love cycle of life
is insane whatever yeah do you feel the
love I'm impatient to ascend to royalty
that's a that's a classic
what I'm impatient to ascend the Royal I
just can't wait to be king as the joke
dance making oh
I got you Dan but I mean I like Aladdin
personally a little late I like Aladdin
okay let's move on thank you guys
um for members tomorrow we'll be doing
my show but I'll be doing at 12 because
I have my rheumatologist appointment
let's go Rheumatology
shut up let's go check out my blood
I can't wait for the doctor to take a
bottle my blood to go
yeah you got AIDS oh not AIDS sorry
I mean I mean lupus
you're not hypothetical does he taste it
HIV in it
the hell like I just had a uh the baby
moment
not quick I'm kidding I'm kidding we
respect our our fellows with AIDS
you weren't disrespectful they were just
I don't know I was just confused yeah
well it is what it is guys anyway this
movie
this is literally I hate this movie so
much and goddamn anyone who was involved
in the creation of this I gotta say I
have avoided I haven't seen any of their
live-action adaptations this one I saw
just because I love Aladdin I was like
it might be entertaining just to watch
how bad
the Lion King was so bad worse than
Aladdin I think in my opinion the live
action man this man is straight up in
blue face
the face caused the entanglement
oh it was off doing blueface
and you lost all respect for him
so uh as I was saying yeah so tomorrow
I'll be live for members who I love
thank you guys so much at 12 o'clock
that'll be fun time for everybody thank
you our members again
um let's move on we've got here today
some okay we're talking about this Drake
Bobby thing with us coming up that's
been a huge deal they had a falling out
which marriage from analysis chill
it almost sounds save it do it again
it's like chill dude
uh we're gonna talk about oh God there's
more Crowder
um gossip that's so good I love crowd
did you watch the video are you gonna
live react to it you watch the longer
version no oh I just saw the part where
he was like send your yeah to my email
address I can't wait for you to see the
same thing you missed a good part yeah
yeah xqc is still coming after me can
you guys believe that no
he's still mad he has to have learned
his lesson by now he hasn't here's what
he said he's called me guess what guys
old
no
he said the one thing that I can never
tolerate anybody's saying about me it
hits way too hard
and I've issued All of You official
warnings for that 43 joke it's not funny
I had to HR reach out to all you
individuals
it's not funny it's a joke it's ageism
Olivia stop old man your HR is getting
reached out to you get over 40 your
memory starts to slipping just
play along just play along
okay and I can get it I'm messaging HR
right now which is not funny right all
right so here's xqc let's see
foreign
that is unobtainable I'm further in a
lot of capacities right yet still
younger and he ain't dude you want
that's the real capacity are you further
than me
genuinely curious
I mean he has more money but like
yeah how much more money
it just matters
at a certain point it doesn't matter it
doesn't really matter like very much
diminishing returns there clear clearly
you have enough money Ethan you know
what I mean thank you Dan and I happen
and I mean that in the most positive way
thank you I mean I don't wake up every
day with the sole purpose of going out
and making as much money as possible
Felix so you can have that one it's fine
it's great no money can buy that no
watch or diamond or whatever the
we'll be able to buy that
Okay so he's a Time billionaire now this
man is like 10 years my my junior
um get protect yeah so that makes him a
pro and if I'm 38 that makes him a prop
approximately 25 percent younger than me
he's a Time billionaire that's not yeah
then I'm also a billionaire I'm also a
Time billionaire by his own master of a
billionaire because he has more of it
good and also like is that
[Music]
um
okay it wasn't a good one apparently we
had a whole committee over that one and
we decided to hit it yeah hit it it was
borderline but yeah
so I was gonna say
oh thanks I'm reading his chat thanks
Steven Mick 44 you're both
cringe all right well maybe you're a
cringer because you're the one watching
him at least
I don't know if that what that means
what did I do
so um
I don't know if that's the flex you want
again it's like you're gonna do you know
how time works
you're gonna be old too bro yeah but
he's just saying he's so much further in
life at such a younger age I think
that's what I'm interpreting from this
so I don't really agree with this
assessment well let's analyze it no I
mean he's right he's young you're 43.
I'm 38. you're 43.
right 38. I yeah again you're just so
confusing let's say an analyzer right he
has is he in a
what's his relationship status
uh he seems uh single yeah wasn't I I
wasn't following but I saw I think he's
going through I think he might be more I
think he might be more single than ever
after this weekend
oh right so not only that he had some
kind of Gossip here this weekend so he's
going through a divorce and
his ex-girlfriend from before her came
out and said he cheated on her after oh
is after after oh after my time here Ian
just dropped the Lincoln yeah here's the
link so I mean has had a bad weekend
like a really bad week is this really
the time to be bringing me back up what
happened
so this girl was like yeah he cheated on
me that's why he broke up nobody knew
what what happened
so many people this man broke up with
his ex-wife
on stream you remember that people had a
massive falling out yeah what yeah they
had a massive falling yeah on stream
that's insane like dude
dude
okay
this whole group man let's keep
analyzing confirm or deny
um he wanted to lie about it he said I
will confirm he wanted to lie about it
so bad I think um
I think a uh
lengthy
thing about nobody cares so okay in
terms of relationship
and family and I don't know if that's
what's it it's not important to
everybody but I do know that he is
looking for a significant other I mean
he's clearly dating he's looking you
know what I mean
so let's say we don't have to bring the
kids into it because not everybody wants
kids but in terms of you know monogamous
uh meaningful relationships I'd say I
take the dub yeah I think that's fair
yeah it's hard you know it's hard to
do objective analysis because like you
said people value different things but
um okay his life does seem to be in
shambles well he does seem to be
embarrassed by the fact he cheated he
didn't want to admit it right yeah he
should he's embarrassed by what happened
with his ex-wife he he won't even
mention her name on on stream right
because he's just may or may not be
ex-wife he sounds like an incredible
partner it's just oh yeah you know he's
he's amazing oh yeah also like by the
way I don't know where this adds in but
he sits in a room full of garbage 22
hours a day right and so in terms of
being a viable mate even though I know
you are very wealthy the sitting in a
heap of garbage thing may be a challenge
for some people garbage
you know
now in terms of uh so okay now another
what other terms are we talking about
here what else do we have
did we talk about um money that he has
more money he does have more money yeah
it's kind of the end of the conversation
and time I feel like he's got money in
time he's he's not like
he's not a billionaire
I feel like me and him are he's a Time
billionaire right
I feel like me and him are basically as
Rich yeah for sure and he's losing money
fast he lost a million this week but
that's right yeah so take I mean if he
loses a million a week you're the man
I'd say you have more money right yeah
yeah within the next three years yeah
just
you know what let's come talk to me
let's get our bank accounts out it
that'd be the corniest ever yeah
all right bro show me your bank account
let's do this maybe he's like you ever
see that movie clock Stoppers
no what where is this going maybe he's
like got some like device or
some his watch he can stop him yeah
yeah like the clock Stoppers like yeah
the 2001 uh young adult adventure 2002.
oh okay now it also came out which is a
surprise to nobody that he also has a
crushing Adderall habit now here's my
question for you guys no I know I know I
know no here's my question what he has
he clearly has ADHD or some you know I
wouldn't be surprised if he does yeah
probably so if he's taking medicine
that's prescribed to him that's fine
however
I feel pretty confident saying he's not
taking it as prescribed
if he's taking 10 a day as it was said
yeah which is pretty common with
Adderall even when it's prescribed
um
people develop a tolerance and start to
abuse it
dude I had I thought you just stream for
three days straight without sleeping I
mean I don't know why you think he's
tweaking so in terms of sleep I take the
dub
hahaha
sleep time this man sleeps let me tell
you all
sleeps I stay slow sweet billionaire
um
sleep billionaire
but you know listen
I had a prescription of Xanax
a few years ago and I was just taking it
I started taking it recreationally
and after a few months I was like this
is so bad and I told my my psychiatrist
do not renew my
prescription anymore
I don't want it
right
and that's what I'm saying you you
there's a big difference when you have a
prescription to a
to a drug that also is a scheduled a
scheduled drug it's habit forming real
fast
but I don't know much about Adderall I
always found that thing really bizarre
like that is a hard drug and they give
that to kids they give it to old people
I don't understand that what yeah I
personally I just ticket like during
finals week and stuff like I would use
it when I needed to
um but yeah I had friends who would take
it pretty regularly for school and
working they're not the only ones yeah
everybody was doing that a lot of most
of them were prescribed like a lot of
people are yeah I was yeah
I have ADHD I mean lots of people that
legitimately have ADHD I've they've told
me that when they take Adderall it it
chills them out yeah yeah I do not yeah
I mean I I don't have that so when I've
taken an Adderall before I'm with you
Ethan I'm like holy crap yeah I took it
once and I hated it I couldn't sleep I
was I was jittery I was anxious it was
not good it was not a fun thing
stop take your Adderall I don't give a
just saying it's a habit-forming
drug okay if you're taking 20 Adderalls
a day you need to stop
yeah you don't need to but it's my
suggestion
you don't I mean
I don't know
but okay whatever we all have issues I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna
for being a drug addict I mean we all
have issues sure I take drugs every
morning
any other dubs I can Flex on them before
nah you know just let him stew let him
stew
yeah I believe him it's prescribed but I
don't think they gave him as much as he
takes
yeah yeah of course
I don't buy that
I need more Adderall right now where's
the credits and where's the prescription
I need to meet my dealer you know why
you know why xuc went in the uh
the lion's head and the Oasis
to get more Adderall
Aladdin reference anybody yeah instead
of the lamp
he never had a drug like me you ain't
never had a drug never had a job but
I'll tell you I'll tell you Aladdin is
definitely on Adderall or I mean a lot
of Genie's on Adderall oh Genie
he's cracked out yeah Jesus Christ
rip to the goat dude yeah I ripped to
the go that one hit me hard man I love
him
Jamie says she's one month sober today
congratulations hey congrats Jamie let's
all shame Ethan for taking lupus meds
next month bro
do you not see what I'm saying Adderall
is healthier than Coke do you not do you
all really just want to take your
Adderall
I'm not saying don't take the Adderall
just saying
just saying there you could clearly
abuse the drug come on guys let's be
real about it I'm not judging you if you
take Adderall every once in a while or
take a bunch of it all the time I don't
give a
I use plenty of drugs in my life
probably should have kept that to
yourself
but if you are taking a lateral a lot a
lateral
probably
rub a lamp lateral
but anyway okay whatever take your drugs
people I don't care
I agree it's not the best point of uh
criticism hey dude I used to be a
straight I was like borderline
addict tube Tramadol so
you know what I mean
I got nothing to say about that
addiction is tough
uh
[Music]
new Chrome extension that I recommend
everybody install by the way
okay do we have this installed yet
oh I didn't install it but we have the
Mr Beast one
that puts his face on every thumbnail
well now we have an xqc one
and this is a this is literally like
what his channel looks like isn't that
interesting this is so funny check it
out
yo this is this is his channel
oh
yeah I recommend everybody get this
really good oh high level stuff
thank you
time billionaire xqc flip
I'm still a billionaire he's on a
collision course to I want to make that
joke in terms of let's see who lives
longer bro I'm doing pretty good I'm
willing to bet that my ass is going to
live longer than him
let's put money on the table bro death
package
let's do it let's do a death I'll put in
the will clearly should take out life
insurance policies on each other oh
that'd be good that's a good idea
that's a really good idea
I wonder if we could do that
um I've heard of have you heard about
like companies taking random life
insurance on their like old employees
and then just silently collecting on
their desks I remember hearing something
about that dude it's so crazy
that's awesome crazy
yeah I don't know I'm feeling like
God bless
just saying he's not a picture of Health
time billionaire excuse me
you hear that time billionaire you hear
the Bell
three days no sleep ding four days no
sleep
apparently it was uh Walmart
what it was Walmart Walmart sued for
collecting life insurance on employees
the craziest scumbag ever they
didn't tell the family they didn't tell
the significant others they just quietly
collected millions of their dead
employees as a just straight up as a
business proposition I don't even think
they knew it
I'm reading through the article right
now latron
they just realized that they can like
make a pretty good
a pretty good bet
on their employees dying
which is you know not a conflict of
interest or anything
they're like hey can you die soon please
trying to get paid you go restock the
top shelf exactly
[Music]
we discovered that uh employees with
health insurance benefits were driving
forklifts and lifting off the highest
shelves
on a routine basis
[Music]
there it is I hope he lives a long time
you know what else can I say
he's a good guy we'd love xqc don't we
um
oh did we never show this one you guys
are gonna love this
oh Rich Lux in the house
yes sir Ethan Klein will outlive us all
thank you Rich love now now that's what
I like to hear
that is the queen you can't do nothing
wrong
I can never Outlet outlive you rich
and ride Space Mountain without Dan
Rooney
no you gotta retire that one do you know
what we need to do I want Dan and Rich
Lux to do a couple's Disneyland do
anything oh my God because the two of
you guys having the best time ever will
you send us VIP
I'll buy you tickets
I don't know maybe next time we do VIP
we should invite Rich box oh my God
and then will you ride every ride with
him yeah of course that's awesome yeah
VIP I'll go you hear that rich are you
down for that yeah no problem with that
block me
so fun set it up so uh shout out to when
all the crew ran into xqc at amaranth
party and this is just such a fantastic
moment I mean it's fantastic you guys
well done to all you thank you yeah here
it is hey uh I'd like to present you
guys uh what's the name a b a b we do
for a living I work for the H3 podcast
this is Asia podcast this guy I
don't know why why was he we already had
beef back then he just said that you
remind him of the opossum underneath his
house but what happened back then I
didn't wait you really no what happened
was it the Hut it was the Hut yeah oh
yeah you had like the Hut happened uh
longer ago it did happen longer ago but
he still I don't know why he came back
up I feel like he was responding to
drama you were in
um he's like Ethan Klein he looks like
the old possible could it be the uh
Chestnut was he yeah yeah I think it was
actually yeah okay I'll take the I'll
take that that the middle finger for
that one but he he talked to me and Ian
prior to this video and he was really
nice he was just like oh you know just
you know online stuff like I hope it
doesn't I hope you guys aren't actually
no no it's whatever okay
I'm not mad at him
I'm not you know anyway here it is so AB
got him first
my name is Cameron
dude oh okay same guy um anyway uh
moving on yeah
[Music]
um yeah uh I like this I like this it's
really nice um maybe one day when I'm
comfortable with um show my dick anyway
uh hello uh what's your name Sam nice to
meet you Sam what are you for living H3
podcast just rice stuff
um I'm just kidding what's your name I'm
Olivia Olivia once again
I work for the H3 podcast
comedy right now
okay I'm out of here
keep it going bro yeah
honestly you don't know um a little bit
of a drama with H3 in a minute comment
about them that was like kind of rude
I'm sorry these guys uh what was it mad
but it was whatever okay the opossum
comment wow took deep offense to that
one
um how did you guys set that up it
worked out so funny and good I kept
calling him you could kind of hear if
you listen close by ask ask him ask her
ask her ask her okay yeah that was great
it worked out so good I mean my goodness
um somebody bought me a sticker super
effective by Lil bori
I don't see those very often bought a
few hmm
you say they bought a few oh thank you
to the sticker Queen
uh it's like uh about a hundred dollars
worth of stickers thank you so much
and thank you so much to little bobri no
comment
zamas wanted to Ethan to know that I
haven't been active on the H3 videos for
a couple months but you my friend have
lost weight looking good well thank you
so much thank you I appreciate that I've
been working harder you know thank you
I'm at 190 things are moving good you
know
um I was afraid that it would start to
slow down a lot when I started to
get in the lower numbers but things are
still moving really good
so my goal was 180 but you know things
are moving good should I might go down
even more 170.
goddamn boy you know
I got a neck again
me and Khalid are both on that weight
loss send me that video
together we're stronger
Khalid together we're stronger tell
everybody the cappuccino you gotta feel
like Al Pacino like cappuccino
I'm so happy College back you guys I
just typed into Google Dr Khalid instead
of DJ Khaled who's Dr Khaled
Kim I'm sure to me in that moment it's
his alter ego where he's a dentist that
works next to Jimmy Lee
cappuccino
uh can you send me the neck one
yeah me and Kelly are both losing a lot
of weight
he goes I got a neck again
uh shout out to John from Portugal the
Man we had a really touching beautiful
connection with him
on Friday he shared really intimate
details of his life about his daughter
who has a rare genetic disorder
he has a GoFundMe to help fund research
and such and I'm real proud of the
fupert Troopers you guys really came
through I mean my goodness man I think
he was at 170. oh wow yeah whoa I mean
yeah it's not quite a bit
there was one guy a fupa trippy donated
25 I see that Chris Putin yeah whoa
unbelievable I think people were saying
they know who he is
[Music]
yeah
put Putnam Putnam
but thanks to you guys and everybody we
it looks like we donated seventy
thousand dollars that that is amazing
you that you look at the best so nice
so so nice so
um happy we were able to do that for him
and John is very appreciative yeah um he
he texts me after and he's like that was
just unbelievable and um he gives many
things for uh coming to talk about it
yeah I'm glad I like that it's just an
unexpected beautiful that's what happens
here on the a Street podcast you know
what I mean
take your time get close on the show my
neck
we'll say I got 15 pounds slim call me
Slim Jim take your time I got a neck now
back up back up I got a neck now that
video
yo it looks like he got her new teeth
too a lot of energy those teeth are
shiny boys
clothes show them the show my neck
you're saying I get 15 pounds slim call
me Slim Jim
it's like his teeth have no
there's no separation between them
it's just like once just a bar across
the top that's the new meta it's just so
hot we don't need individuals yeah why
look at that it's so bright you
can't even see the damn lines
divides right there take it down
I love them yeah they were stronger
College back uh he's back bring out the
whole neck
tell them to bring out the whole ocean
cappuccino
we got more what's this baby I believe
uh you're correct he did get new teeth
yeah he got some new peepers there
peepers creepers jeepers
creepers
I know you longer needs separation
between my teeth they all just one tooth
yeah should I do oh did he oh he posted
about it the temps are in boys the
pearly whites porcelain they'll be here
this week and you can't part of the
network
the dentist Network he definitely
hold it that's a good question
the dark the dark dentist Network would
anybody do this I've
what the get their teeth fixed yeah
that's like the crazy Hollywood oh the
crazy Hollywood thing we do no it's so
in it's like every famous person is
doing this
yeah you know that's how Hollywood is is
always like the some beauty fat or
another and they're all jumping on
some of these break my heart a little
bit because like this dude
what happened here exactly
uh it looks like
it doesn't close fully it's like a
slight uh overbite overbite okay because
they both look good so yeah it's not
that bad this is this is like this yeah
this is like good veneers because it
doesn't look too unnatural
yeah yeah I worked with uh These Guys
these two doctors in Michigan they're
very well known uh for doing veneers and
I kind of know a little bit about them
from them but yeah a lot of mistakes
that a lot of cheat people that do
veneers they they make them too white
I guess they ask you but thing is I
don't want the dentist to ask me how
wide I want it because I don't know yeah
those right I'll be like I want a super
white and then you come out looking like
a gut like DJ Khaled with one tooth yeah
those two big two those two doctors I'm
talking about they'll never ask their
patients like if a doctor asks you then
you should leave them it's smart yeah
good advice
if I was to do one cosmetic surgery I'd
do the teeth I think
I don't like my teeth
your teeth are fine
they look weird when I smile fold it
really I think yeah I'm surprised to
hear you say that your teeth are fine
every time I see your teeth I think of
that zarna video where you zoom in very
close to your teeth
like that licking your lips yeah
but it'd be a shame though to shave them
off and all that you did right yeah I
don't have any cavities I got good teeth
you know yeah exactly why are you even
why would you even consider it I'm not
you're blessed I'm not doing it
oh well I don't know if this counts but
I want to laser like the hairs off my
ears
that counts and sure that's cosmetic
surgery it's not surgery I guess it's
not technically surgery well they call
it like I don't know
is they've probably called a procedure
cosmetic procedure no not yeah I guess
procedure or whatever but as I get older
I get these hairs on my ear and
I remember as a kid looking at my
grandpa and his hair the inside of their
ear turns into like a little forest in
there it looks like a work like a goon
worm's mouth wicker basket looks cool
dude looks like a wizard and I thought
it was so gross so I'm gonna laser that
I'm not gonna I'm so right it does
look like a wizard looks like Gandalf
yeah yeah I had an uncle oh I had
an uncle from Lebanon he only came when
I was a kid I do not remember his face
but I could see his ears clearly
it scared me as a child Franklin
and I thought that's never gonna happen
to me and now I see they hit their hairs
are starting to come in so I'm gonna I'm
gonna Vape zap that zap it I'm
gonna vaporize it do you
um
we should do our ad you know what else I
do this is So Vain and absurd I'm not
gonna do this but it would be so vain
and absurd and I would do it if I cared
maybe if I was single you know I mean I
come out with the teeth
I would feel dude I will get a hair
transplant to fill in the
patches in my beard bro really you know
you can oh bad ass would that be like
powder or Pro there's product to
if you want a one day experiment with
yeah to fill it to fill your beard you
mean makeup yeah oh that exists I feel
it can be odd I yo you with your fingers
I'm with you on that I got like the same
exact spot right tell me right here I
got it kind of lined up so you can't
really see it but there's just a big
circle where it doesn't grow right here
my barber always has to go like super
high up it doesn't look weird though the
way it's lined up I think I do too look
at this bro because if I could if I
if I trim it here
um
it looks crazy bad
like yeah no that's not a good look this
one where it's like the chicken strap
like that yeah
that's not great yeah like uh your
fingers in your chin George Lucas
and then look at this right right here
what'd I say I meant George Lucas
you said George Lucas I did say George
Lucas I think so
somebody somebody says thank you okay I
just I recorded Lucas oh I didn't hear
you say that
so there those are my two cosmetic uh
thank you Luke also I would I would
tattoo my eyes black
oh yeah
right if you were just doing a couple
things yeah maybe you just get that like
crazy like snake eyes
yeah this is straight up what I'd look
like if I tried to shave the
spots out
would you ever would you ever you gotta
see him from this side I know him that's
what I'm looking for yeah what Dan would
you ever um it's a small thing but would
you ever uh split your tongue like cut
your tongue so it's like a snake tongue
that's all I would do that yeah if I
tattooed my eyes black yeah that'd be
sick and be really sick
yeah I don't know
it's pretty cool what you can do these
days though
um okay moving on so we have our sponsor
we have one sponsor I'm gonna thank them
real fast and we'll keep moving on here
do it we've got so much to talk about
new scooter video
oh that's big news this tick tocker is a
literal
demon crazy what's his name
Dylan
Dylan page okay this story is
unbelievable this is literally me if I
try to line myself up this is what I
would look like and no offense to My Boy
George but King ain't nobody forever
ain't nobody trying to have a necklace
he has some interesting neck he really
does it's just straight yeah interesting
frog like
it's an interesting neck I don't want
any part of
it that's so wow
[Music]
this uh Elite Libo
what is it Libo Brie Lee bobri
go ahead well I'm sorry I'm saying the
name wrong but uh they sent like five
more of those 50 stickers they're
loading us up I love stickers little bow
breathe little bow breed yeah little bow
breed okay I wasn't all right let's
thank our sponsor thank you to them
thank you all you guys let's go ahead
and talk about gamer sup for a minute
speaking of which I need to start
hitting my Gamers up
new flavors coming out we have a date
people 8 25.
H3 flavors coming out 8.25
what's the what flavor is it I can't say
it's spicy Margarita
also that's the flavor but it's called
out Sigma brain Sigma brain baby it's a
little spicy
you're gonna love this
actually you are gonna love it it's a
little Tangy it's a little sweet it's a
tiny bit spicy it is the flavor to end
all flavors I'm very happy in the
laboratory as a group perfecting
twisting tweaking a little too much of
that a little too little of this
in the lab tweaking tweaking it's
happening more acidity more acidity
Morrison exactly it says it gotta hit a
spicier a little acidier
it's all happening this month August
25th
super hyped about it
it's the best flavor in the world not
because it's mine
but because
I hate her that good oh yeah
now until then I mean I would recommend
my my jam is black cherry
that one keeps me going it keeps me
strong
yeah I know you all have your own
preferences dancing mango boy no blue
Raz although the mango is good I'm the
mango boy he's the mango boy but I've
been hitting the pine lately the
pineapple
the thing about gamer sub that's so cool
they have so many flavors and they're
all good
you know it's a lot of fun just to try
different flavors every month you get a
new you know but it's time to re-up
um like this one anime girl thought
it's fairly good reviews it's a beloved
flavor
[Music]
it's a summer flavor incredible summer
flavored somehow mild it doesn't feel
heavy on my tongue tastes like an orange
creamsicle cheers it's anime girl thigh
yeah I'm excited though for you guys to
try this we also getting our own shaker
cup which we lovingly crafted we went
through many iterations we actually
sought out super talented artists spent
a lot of money commissioning art
and
the result
we're all very happy
shout out kizzy have we talked about
what's on it
uh no we haven't really talked about the
shaker cup at all as a matter of fact
because I wasn't sure if it was coming
out at the same time as the flavor
actually I'm not still not sure about
actually so maybe we shouldn't be
talking about it yet but well let's Get
Hype going sure so at first a lot of
creators who've done this kind of collab
with them they just dry themselves with
titties and call it a day but I didn't
want to go that route yeah
because though we respect people who do
well for sure but I thought let's build
up you know my best asset my best
quality why people respect me the most
my masculinity yep
and so we're like God what's it going to
look like
and then I had it
the perfect inspiration
a Full Metal Alchemist the butcher from
Fullmetal Alchemist I said this is
no way not the butcher no yeah this guy
oh you're right you're right it was this
guy no I think these two guys beef cakes
I was thinking of the other one the one
that he's shaking hands with in that
other picture this is cool but the vi
the vibe is definitely him yeah
he's a Beefcake they're both beef cakes
but guess what they're jacked they're
monsters they're beasts the masculinity
oozes from every poor in their body just
like me
[Music]
so this is what you guys can come to
expect look at those arms man I'm
telling you about oh my gosh this is
what you guys have come to yeah yeah
it's gonna be good by the way I love
this uh these two guys Full Metal
Alchemist
check it out yeah good show
but anyway
uh gamer sup Nation
it's gonna be great
but until then you can go to
gamersupps.gg and use the code H3 to get
10 off your order and uh I appreciate
that you know love gamer Subs a
fantastic partner please consider
supporting them if you're in the
market for some delicious tasting energy
hydrating beautiful beverage
let's keep it going
yes let's keep it going before game or
sub uh-huh
bring up the whole game or something
all right
Jimmy well speaking of cosmetic surgery
real fast Jimmy Lee okay what the
is this dude this was a sponsored post
it sure was
is
injectables are for everyone although
it's common to associate plastic surgery
with females or more males are circling
out options for facial Rejuvenation I
don't think that's true anymore hold it
what they says plastic surgery is
associated with females
oh that's the part that you're saying is
not true yeah well maybe I just been
watching she agrees
well what is Jimmy doing in this
I don't know did he look at he's got the
hairline here dude they painted on
hairline and the before up old
natural beautiful hairline Jimmy Jimmy
take this to Heart
the unpainted on hairline made it in the
after image
these people know what they're doing
but there's no shot that this is
wearing makeup on the right I don't I
don't I don't know look you can like see
the make
there's something very odd about this
dude postdocs can't make you go from
this to this he looks really pumped
I did I think it can but yeah this is
what it does the neck is what's throwing
me off tight Little Neck oh that
might just be chopped out look at how
massive his forehead is it's like
that's what I'm saying I don't think so
I've seen lots of people get BOTOX it
doesn't really do this it just makes
your face look weird I think this might
be some elaborate prank I don't know
this is a real go to the I know that has
to be real can we get Jimmy on the phone
we have to I can uh try and set that up
so confused here is the plastic surgeon
that performed this for him
and she's got lots of Dubs here
uh including Jimbo
so weird our very own doctor Jimmy James
weiner
just randomly it says the above image is
an actual photo of a client
and like the disclaimer at the bottom of
the text here's the thing too
this was a sponsored post that's how
people found it yeah
so not only did Jimbo go in there but
they're they're paying to spread it
maybe because he's a celebrity no 100
they probably saw that he has a quarter
of a million followers on Instagram
yeah no wonder he's like yo listen hook
me up
a mega famous I don't pay you can use it
I got a million followers that is he
definitely is like full of Botox and
filler in that photo like overflowing
you think so I think I do I think it
looks wonderful it's probably but I
don't think it's photoshopped I think
that that's real no I think it's I think
it's airbrushed he looks sorry
no offense Jimmy but you look old as
in this one well that's the old
hymn
diversions well wasn't he born in the
90s
he said 90s kid yeah which means you
know he was just a child in the 90s yeah
he's a child in the 20s as well
could have been
born anywhere from
1985 to 1999. Jimmy put on his fake
hairline to go get his plastic surgery
it's so funny
love that about him
also here he has eyebrow makeup too it
looks like it does look like her and
here he's gone on all natural Jimmy you
look good all natural buddy
it's possible he tints them and it's
just lightened up a bit
I think the right is as natural as his
followers
died and his skin is just permanently
dyed underneath too
he looks like Phil or just eyebrows yeah
but is that what boy talk says it just
gets rid of your wrinkles yeah
it's it swells things to basically
stretch out the skin damn this did
really good for him he looks really good
I agree it wears off though it wears off
in like yeah
[Music]
just permanent swelling is like the most
toxic uh substance known to man yeah so
little of it
that it makes your face swell
for six months
load me up baby Jimmy's gonna have
Pillow face I think I was looking up
before the show the the equivalent of um
one like human cell size of the toxin is
lethal to a human yeah I'd like to know
who've discovered that by the way
that you could inject it into what if we
just put like a really tiny bit of
mountain what would happen Wild
the last 15 last 50 test patients have
died doctor
just a little less just a little less
dude you look amazing
there it is Jimmy Lee we'll have to ask
him about that but congratulations on
the new look Zach's out trying to get
him on the line right now I love to hear
from him it's been a while yeah
that kind of
we saw him like a month ago yeah it
feels like it's been too long
uh we got a new scooter video guys
let's go which is always a treat
always a treasure
this one takes place in what it looks
like to be a convenience store
here it is
you're gonna have to mute that
oh right Zach's on the phone sorry oh
he's on the phone here I'll meet it
I got you you go ahead
so this woman looks like she's
restocking oh my God she's working there
trying to do her goddamn job and this
maniac
is Out For Blood I think this woman has
a hit on her or something look at that
that was a malicious takedown well that
should have moved out of the way
kidding no you're right it's her
obligation it's the people's obligation
around the scooter to move for real yeah
right of way dude she takes her
out dude
yeah they just get so confused on those
things man they don't know what's the
break they know it's the gas
this was uh Dianne Feinstein on her way
to Congress
you know after this she went and voted
on a bill to uh
that affects 350 million people
this lady does not get paid enough for
this
me
dude I love scooter videos you guys it
just doesn't get better
I mean we're arming the most
how do I word this uh
in a way that doesn't make me seem like
an
[Music]
um I don't think you do
we are arming old people with deadly
weapons they are riding around on
Torpedoes literally taking people out
and nobody says anything
nobody cares there is an epidemic of
scooters literally slaying people of
this country no around the world
and it's time that we as non-scooter
people stand up as an organization and
say stand up as an organization stand up
which they wish they could do
stunt on them
and say gnome this farther and no
further
scooter Nation
rise the up
hey
here's Jimmy Lee
this looks really good
what happened here
so I uh I gave him like two calls and
text him and he like big time does
yeah he's pretty big time he's busy
he's doing all kinds of deals with
dentists plastic surgeons
we we respect and love our uh
our wheelbound uh patriotic friends I do
think though we probably I'll be honest
a little regulation on the speed and
power of these things would probably be
a good idea
I mean how many people have died each
year from scooter related accidents
hundreds thousands thousands you know
what I mean I don't know if I've heard
of any and then what God forbid they're
driving off cliffs probably all over the
place they're losing excuse me sir just
it's just a whole damn
it's a whole damn catastrophe out there
scare me if you see an old person on a
scooter walk the hell around them
because those things could go any which
way any speed man you are not safe it's
like a lightning strike
mm-hmm
that's my advice senior citizen Kamikaze
military branch somebody said
if we ever go to Ward again I think we
need to draft the senior citizens and
give them the ultimate scooter that they
always wanted no regulation Ultimate
speed
say
[Applause]
old Jerome
you've been you lived through a lot
you live through the Great Depression
Great Depression and two world wars
time to go out and Ablaze the glory
this here scooter reached atop 100 miles
per hour it's strapped with 20 pounds of
TNT
I need you
to floor it to the front iron
I even got a little American flag on the
back flipping red in the Wind
I mean you even got this little horror
let them know you're coming beep beep
beep beep beep beep beep beep beep
there's a whole platoon of
senior citizen kamikaze
drivers thousands of them in a row which
army wouldn't flee in fear of that
some are parachuting from the
sky
dropped from cargo airplanes right on
top of the enemy line who's not running
my resolution
strikes
just warned the Ukraine would be done in
three days if we drop the senior citizen
Kamikaze Brigade bomb them
you got nothing left to live for
time to do the ultimate service to this
country
you ran over enough people back home now
it's time to run over the enemy beep
beep beep
the geriak at Calvary
is in order
God bless you
and when you die for your country
it's going to be Bingo forever 52
virgins to play vingo with I don't know
that's inappropriate
it's like a Isis thing
they're not in Isis
they're not
although they're not in anything this is
a complete fictional Universe although
they might I mean Isis might do the
same because I'm putting out this level
of military genius might be a mistake
because we could get some Isis scooters
dropped over New York City
maybe and I mean maybe
Kamikaze is nothing to joke about those
boys were lied to listen it's been long
enough we can joke about kamikaze
okay
come give me a break that's a lot better
than world war three
all right let's move on thank you
we were on a lot of tangents today folks
I have to say you have the most
interesting imagination
thank you Zach
thank you Zach you're great at
improvising oh thank you Zach you too I
mean hey you're back there doing all
kinds of creative Magic on that on board
but just like like that and then like
going back to the Nathaniel klansman
like that was all like improvised
but thank you Zachary such a sweet guy
you're glazing me up
foreign
I felt like it kind of lacked a little
bit of direction I think you had the
core of a funny idea there in that rant
but it was taking way too long to like
kind of
tease it out well Dan not to throw you
under the scooter but Dan was sending me
notes and Discord saying get off the
topic because he thought I was going to
offend people a little earlier when you
said uh
yeah old people are all menaces
um well I mean well was I wrong all of
them them at certain points they
all cause a threat to us that's why we
don't don't you ever wonder why we all
put them in a home together
that seems very well it seems uh like a
bad idea in that case well no so they
can hurt each other they don't have much
time left they can't hurt us
Hunger Games you know what I'm saying
yeah
bingo games
Jello games
okay whatever thank you Zach you're a
good boy
uh let's see here a woman pushes the
pastor off stage I saw this I just want
to know what the story was but I don't
think the story is that interesting
unfortunately
here it is
Praise Jesus if God is exists then why
didn't he stop this checkmate
dude
kind of a Vibe though
that's an old video we watched this on
the show what yeah
unless it happened again
no it's from 2019. yeah we what like
back then we watched it oh
where did this even like I'm him
I think I saw it on Tick Tock or
something or that yeah maybe the sub and
I just thought what's the story here uh
yeah I and if I recall she was having
like a mental health episode it was a
whole thing she had a Moment of clarity
yeah
apparently this dude's like the biggest
Pastor in like Brazil right I remember
that it was from Brazil yeah we 100 he
was preaching to 50 000 people in Brazil
I don't know how this woman broke the
Rings
thank God she'd have a knife or
something she was just there to shove
him
let me make sure I'm not Crossing it
with another story here
I'm going to let's see I'm going to
attack Pastor Marcel Ross during a
service in Brazil in front of 50 000
people during his sermon Pastor was
preaching about how fat women can't go
to heaven what what what hold on what
are you reading this he said in one
article fat women can't go to heaven
finally someone's saying it
hold on many reports David that that
woman pushed him out of protest and
anger okay that woman is a is a hero for
a very different story than the one I'm
reading so you guys feel fat women just
women what about fat men they're good
there were a lot of Articles somewhere
hold on hold on Portuguese what about
your homie here this guy's looking a
little chubby is he getting into heaven
I mean what the
he's homies with God it's fine
what Zach sorry I was just I mean this
guy's cracking me up there were like a
few articles majority were in like
Portuguese
um but from what I saw is like yeah this
guy's a Victorious like anti-gay and
just like kind of a huge piece of
okay yeah so she the story both stories
could be true she could have been having
a mental health issue but from what I
saw he was preaching about fat women
can't go to heaven so listen you
shouldn't take fat woman lightly because
you were talking saying fat women
can't go to heaven and this woman
somehow snuck him back broke the Rings
even God couldn't stop her and she was
able to snipe your old skinny ass so all
I'm saying is
don't count the fatties out because
they're coming for you
a lot of these articles that I'm looking
at uh they're in a different language
but this one right here has an update it
says the initial article said the woman
allegedly pushed him for saying fat
woman don't go to heaven later on the
motive behind the action was later found
out to be inconsistent with the fact
since the story was updated
uh whatever it was she's in the right
also he's anti-gay he had it coming
looked like he almost flew
no
oh my what's the can you play the Kelsey
Grammar one when he falls off Zach good
Lord yeah everybody play that when he
falls off
but apparently unfortunately he was fine
I don't want to say that
God softened his fall I guess
maybe he fell on a fat woman that broke
his fall
ironic I'm just saying dude watch your
mouth yeah
watch your mouth dude with that
fat woman
who says that what's the theory behind
that
that fat woman can't go to heaven yeah
right I don't remember that Bible yeah I
never learned Sunday School Miss that
weekend okay Jimmy's gonna call in 30
minutes that's exciting you want the uh
you want him to call him in third yeah I
want to hear from him okay cool I'd like
to know about this Botox story it's
pretty interesting uh Dan can you send
me a link yeah also thank you
yeah I also wanted to ask him about his
Instagram post that showed like
it was a picture of Oppenheimer and it
said sorry not sorry Lowell with a
picture of her Hiroshima it's crazy he
said I know it's up I am so
offensive though he said driving to
dinner
um 6 p.m my time if you want so we're
here Jimbo I feel like he's gonna be
calling he's gonna be calling from a
restaurant yeah well let's see I'll try
I'll tell him don't no paper checking
dude every time we call him he's like
rushing to the restaurants like
you know you remember that video game
that was real popular papers please yeah
yeah that's Jimmy in real life every
time he's at a restaurant
okay well that was that was cool that's
interesting backstory there
the ass sniffer this is exciting news
was caught
the prolific ass sniffer that was
terrorizing Barnes and Noble
uh here in Los Angeles yes
was apprehended thank goodness man we
got a whole news report about it
let's see
yeah since DNA Advanced is no longer
like the night Prowler it's just the ass
sniffer this is big news
which is you know comparatively better
not to not to say this guy is not a
creep oh it definitely is but yeah yeah
a man's under arrest after social media
captured him following a woman and
allegedly invading her Pride pricey
social media influencer Michaela and
Witter was shopping at a Burbank
bookstore this week and he could see it
for yourself here she realized a man was
following her and crouching low as if to
look under her skirt she recorded all of
it and reported it not only to the
bookstore but also to Burbank PD she
also posted it to her social media
accounts a lot of people reacting there
the man was later arrested that was
yesterday in Glendale Police are
investigating whether he's connected to
other similar invasion of private oh
there's a sniffing events and he what is
I mean we've seen him on video before
right another person there was one other
one that came out yeah
it is crazy I never seen ears like that
my whole life never
they're very shrek-like
powder in addition to the the back in
jail man he was arrested on a warrant
for a reported peeping incident at a
Glendale this man gets out of prison and
he just goes straight to Barnes Noble to
stay fast
what he lives for
evidently he throwed it all away just to
sniff some ass
can you just go to a prostitute I guess
that's not the joy he likes the
he likes the thrill of the also I feel
like
I mean listen it's obviously disgusting
and weird but if we just like analyze
this a little bit if you're like
a few like a few feet behind somebody or
even just like a foot away and you're
like can you smell it you know what
smell it he got pretty close he gets
really unless you're like making contact
which maybe he did but like the the
video it seemed like he was like a
little behind her
um how much are you accomplishing with
that it's got to be doing something for
him yeah I guess
I think he smells maybe he's got a crazy
sense of smell
yeah I don't have the best sense of
smell actually so maybe maybe I'm
underestimated I think he's smelling
something if he wasn't he wouldn't be
doing it yeah he probably didn't get
covered or he doesn't have long cover no
yeah no no but this guy is a menace
right like I was saying last time it
starts with this and it and it always
gets worse and crazier and then it gets
violent and then this guy's also a
sudden killing people so let's get him
in prison please and and you know I'm
glad he's out of this he's out of the
swamp back in the prison
foreign
started streaming on Twitch I think it
was fake yeah he just linked his Twitter
I'd love to see him play Minecraft
that'd be pretty cool
but this is a big update and a huge dub
for the people the women of Los Angeles
and all Barnes and Nobles this is a huge
win for Barnes Noble company
Lord knows they need it I'll tell you
man they let that go on too long though
I was about to turn on Barnes and Noble
there ain't nothing Noble about letting
a man sniff ass you establishment
nothing
and what is this a barn
the chat's all actually saying that he
sniffs through his ears interesting
all Barn no Noble get your together
uh what else we got
[Music]
oh my God this was so exciting so a
Super Trooper answered the call
finally somebody did what we've been
asking and asking
she went there with the safety vest
I'm assuming this is her the original
poster yeah it seemed like it by the
comments so first of all thank you so
much for doing this and this is has some
really interesting results guys check it
out my best on as to mimic what the cop
was wearing I don't think anyone
realizes the Trek it takes to get up to
this slide you need to go through all
these holes well done girl
down to the slide a little bit wet on
the inside right cause a little bit of
friction
so I decided to put the vest on my butt
it's just like a diaper I like it
right through there
she comes
yep pretty good and wait there's a
second one
[Music]
Jesus look at that damn she did it it's
not the same nope she went far man look
how far she went the way that that man
caught air is best on you're right
something's like different but this she
got the distance this proves the concept
yes I will say that I think if she wore
pants because you can hear her skin like
sliding towards the Slime it sounds
painful if she had like a nice kind of
nylon in your pants she would have gone
flying for sure
there it is though I think we cracked
the case on that and thanks to her thank
you to you uh benzo babe oh my God
amazing chill up the benzos please not
too many we need you
babe you literally don't die on that
slap I will be there with my daughter
ripping benzos photos that they closed
it did you see I saw they they closed it
yeah that's dumb too much uh too
much excitement
too much wine sorry all right
wait what the people are people in
the office are boycotting Coke Zero
no no this is a Dan thing right he's not
here
what's the deal you like Pepsi Zero now
can I get one of those
yeah you can do you want to try
that they're pretty good actually
this is zero technology is it's it's
Cutting Edge all the zero drinks are so
good I've been drinking the diet pepper
Dr Pepper Dr Pepper
zero and it is so good fantastic
the root beer zero is all happening you
know what I like is uh Sun kiss zero
Liquid Gold it's hard to find
interesting
I gotta say my favorite Red Bull
sugar-free oh yeah it's better than the
original you think so way better I like
because there's so much sugar in the
original it just I feel icky when I take
that much sugar in my body
yeah I like the diet Red Bulls I hit
those too
all right let's get to um one of the
main stories here which is this tick
tocker demon bro I could not believe
that's what I saw with this guy so this
dude's name is Dylan page she's
really big on Tick Tock okay
let me pull up his
uh let me pull him up here Paige can you
uh can you link me his Tick Tock page
but it's about this lady uh everybody
I'm sure is aware
of this viral moment that went massive
massive
this woman was what appeared to me to be
some kind of psychotic break
she seemed to be having psychosis or
delusions or something because she's
saying let's not discount
the ghost Theory
oh or there's ghosts let's not he's so
quick to dismiss her claims well well
here let's watch just to jogging of
memory but she's saying these guys are
fake like they're not real I don't know
here it is
flying look at their attacks yeah right
ouch
stop it
right now
[Music]
foreign
to be honest having gone through or
experienced stuff like this I've told
this story with when I was with this kid
in Israel who
was having a schizophrenic episode I
mean I feel bad for her you know
I think that
she's not being violent even she just
she's having some kind of episode and
a horrible timing for that kind of thing
and I don't know what's the background
here but
you know seeing a lot of people uh
before the theory that it was lizard
people in the chat lizard father it was
actually the lizard folk her dad stop so
or she's telling the truth
also important context Carrot Top was on
the plane allegedly whoa did he did he
have any comment to make uh he just said
initially he thought the lady was
yelling about him
that's a joke he wasn't there
he's not real I mean if I saw a dude
like her thinking if I saw this
sitting on a plane I'd also
have a psychotic break that's 2008.
what's he looking like today oh you know
what I heard him saying he goes
he loves exercising he's a health nut
and he says I love lifting weights but I
had to stop because I look so
weird
so he started jogging instead and
apparently now if we look at Carrot Top
and mad respect to the guy for you know
taking his health seriously but it's not
his muscles that looks weird all right
the whole thing is it's it's so here he
is now the muscles did oh Bro go
back to lifting I don't know
[Music]
um
wait inside his hair
oh it's like his what he's literally
Carrot Top
there's no orange hair anymore what are
you doing well yeah so he lost the
muscle mass no he I like Carrot Top he
gets a he gets too much he's funny
man
I've seen him on stage that dude's funny
when I was a kid I used to watch his
movies
we loved him movies yeah he did movies
they were all like
there's total disasters there's a Carrot
Top movie I went and saw it on my
friend's birthday we had so much fun
there
chairman of the board yeah that's it
chairman of the board wow look at this
2.3 on IMDb let's go
chairman of the board baby yo it says
Corky Romano energy
I like this movie as a kid this is ruled
dude you just can't handle his energy
Surfer an inventor Edison played by
carrotop is chosen by his roommates to
raise rent with his outrageous
inventions
there's no luck in job interviews until
he meets billionaire Armand
uh McMillan who likes him leaves his
company after his death to Edison Edison
has a lot of success with his inventions
while the company's competitors do all
they can to destroy him that sounds like
a recipe for hijinks
it's basically like blank check
which was already a disaster of a movie
but like it was
blank check I opened another movie one
of the most uh inappropriate uh
scenes ever
put to put to film dude I love
this movie when I was a kid you remember
what I'm talking about yeah there's
there's some girl trying to him
when he was like a child yes that's what
it's all about babies blank check
I think they're like trying to play into
like the
the uh teen the young teenage fantasy
the Adolescent fantasy but like straight
up doing pedo they didn't realize
what they were doing
didn't they kiss actually yeah I just
found it that's so gnarly why was she
kissing him because he's not it's not
even like big right where it's like an
old man and a kid this is just a child
this is just a child there's no subplot
here that makes it okay well play it
damn
oh well just just show me when it
happens
or maybe just show you uh wait what why
did it happen that's appropriate for
this what was the context
okay
oh boy does anyone know the context I I
have not seen blink tricks since about
1994 I think I saw it in theaters just
give me like five seconds okay seven six
okay it's a date
bro this is in saying it's this
movie it's blank check okay stop stop
stop stop stop
this movie
is a big part of my childhood is it this
and chairman of the board
yeah I I've only seen it once I believe
and it was it was in theaters
I was excited about it nobody thought
about it back then is that interesting I
want to get hit by a bike that's it
or not hit by bike hit by a car on your
bike on your bike so this this rich guy
hits him backs up destroys his bike on
accident and he goes here kid here's a
blank check I don't know how much your
car costs just have your parents fill it
in with the cost and he goes oh I'm
gonna put a million dollars on it and
then with a million dollars the kid goes
and proceeds to spend like 100 million
dollars right because people have no
concept of how much a million is he buys
like a private airplane a giant mansion
lavish parties I never thought I was
like yeah a million bucks
what is this kid doing
he spot what the was that
hold on let me go back to this
this child was filming her changing
did you see that no I missed it okay
hold on hold on
there it is oh damn yeah the bike yep
yep here's the blank check don't tell
anybody it's a little criminal a million
dollars yep
okay
there's this the girl who's a pedo where
does she come from she's uh undercover
FBI agent right those agents Do Anything
Is that real yeah I believe so why does
she make out with a child at the end I
think she's like investigating it and
then at the end he says should we do a
second date and she says call me in 10
years that's disgusting oh right that's
what they were saying right before so
she gives him a kiss and says call me in
10 years that's yeah
I saw a scene of him filming
outside her bedroom with the of her
changing with a camcorder was insane
hold on
let's be coming up I think it's after
this crayon scene Jesus
a hammer put that hammer down freak is
this the right I think it might have
like changed over to a different I don't
think we're seeing the trailer for blank
check I think it's a compilation of this
actor no of this actor but I refreshed
it
I think this is blank check
there's no way when he took the radio in
he killed him yeah
[Music]
Disney pictures presents this is blank
check this is blank check 100 I think it
got to the end and then it auto played
into another one maybe I was watching
the similar looking kid that's so
funny okay I guess it was
something else
she's got to go to jail
yo the FBI up they'll do anything
to get the job done wow typical anyway
Shadow Carrot Top I don't know where we
were going with this we're talking about
the lady you saw okay yeah Carrot Top
was on the airplane on the airplane
so back to the airplane and which Carrot
Top was sitting apparently
Fox News
pleasure standby protocol
[Music]
we got attorneys out here flexing
laughs
let's go
and there's a reason why I'm getting the
tell everyone they neither Believe
it or they cannot believe it I don't
give two but I am telling you right now
I think part of the issue is all not I
mean the the voice register
it hits like a note that's so high
I think a lot of it resonated with
people to play up the whole Karen angle
I don't know
people perceive this as a Karen video
though it's like yes
they do it's just not well
yeah I feel bad for her I can't believe
it I don't
but I am telling you right now
back there is not real
and you can spit on this plane and you
can dive in them or not I'm not going to
so would you have gotten off the plane
Miss
yeah Olivia just immediately said yes
well listen if there's somebody having a
psychotic break you don't want to go on
a long flight with them necessarily also
I'm saying after she's gone no I'd stay
on them no she was saying like
you'll see you'll see what happens I
think that I would just be like maybe
I'm not gonna fly today I'm not getting
really on a fly today how do you know
that the one you switched to isn't the
one that crashes because it doesn't have
her on it saying you'll see you'll see
maybe she's talking to you specifically
and this is why I have trouble flying
right why because this one lady
or this conversation everything
yeah somebody so said it's like a final
destination uh scene
so um again I I don't know if people so
she's this this person here is not real
and I don't know if she was like Hey
this guy is a phony
no yeah she was saying this guy is not
some kind of real yeah otherworldly so
this video goes mega viral and um
everybody
is trying to figure out who it is for
some sick up reason
[Music]
um
well she's now issued an apology should
we watch that first well here let me
give some of the details first uh let's
see interestingly she's a really
successful marketing executive and
she does really well in life and God
bless her you know what I mean if she
does have some underlying issues and
she's like Medicaid and taking care of
herself I mean that's that's super
impressive and God bless her for that
you know
um
so here's where I have a problem with
this Dylan scumbag
let me pull this up
I've seen this guy's videos before
and I never had a problem with him
uh where's his where's his tick tock
is Tick Tock account or the one that you
want to uh watch oh I got it thank you
his Tick Tock account just to show you
guys so this is Dylan page
number one news account on Tick Tock he
refers to himself
as news Daddy
oh the news daddy of course
here's an example
and his view his videos have a shitload
of views so he's crushing it out
you watch this stuff well when I saw
this video that we're gonna see watching
a bit I had to download it because I was
like no way he keeps this up good
then I forgot about it a while and then
I when she issued the apology I cracked
the dots this really
her up he her like you know like
okay well let me show you guys what he
does he and her brother dying may have
just taken a dog twist as we all know by
now a statement was posted supposedly by
lotte's family and her blogger had
suddenly died but since then the New
York Post is anyway this is what he does
he just says it's like Philip DeFranco
kind of tick tock Edition
this is
and he's very popular I'm looking at
like five seven million 10 11 million
views they're all crushing it so
when in the midst of this drama this
psycho now there's certain
things in here I don't want to show is
it edited
like I don't want to show
yeah uh we blurred
yeah yeah
[Music]
so watch this
for over a month despite it being what's
with the audio is that him or us damn
dude it's all of his videos are
blown out it's crazy hot dude
wait really like play yeah viable videos
of the Year somehow no one could find
I don't remember it sounding like that I
don't maybe something happens all right
whatever let's watch sorry guys get on
with it over a month despite it being
one of the most viral videos of the Year
somehow no one could find out the
identity of this woman leading to a lot
and I mean a lot of people believing
that she was the one that wasn't real
but now okay so far
I get it who is she we don't know okay
now this
well thanks to a journalist called Bria
Dale she has officially been identified
so okay now let me tell you this is not
blurred in his Tick Tock definitely not
it has her age
well race sex ethnicity it has her
address her City her it doesn't have her
exact address she blank that up but he
had city state ZIP code County okay and
that's not it and her a picture of her
face all right it's Tiffany she is her
full her full name yep and then this is
more identifying information about her
company this says who her employer is
yep and like their phone number their
address name of company address or like
location of company her role in the
company this woman didn't do anything
why are you trying to ruin her
life you little freak but wait it gets
even worse than the founder of a in
called he says the name the location the
number is on the screen
according to public records Tiffany is a
graduate of State University and lives
in a 2 million
and said her neighborhood what is wrong
with you dude he's doing it so like
happy-go-lucky and like casually like
just no not even really thinking about
it at all why is that pertinent
information and what is wrong with you
that you didn't realize you shouldn't be
doing this I think this deserves a
permanent ban like you are not
responsible enough to have a
platform this is insane
it's so bizarching because I watched
this dude every day right and then he
dropped this and I was like Milo what
the are you doing you're ruining
This Woman's life for no reason yeah
she's the owner of that business by the
way so oh said she's an executive okay
okay maybe she's not but she's like Top
Dog right so she's sure that heard their
employee I don't know if she was fired
because she's not said a lot right but
she may have been I wouldn't be
surprised so it was yeah exactly it's so
up crazy and she's in like a
really accomplished job she's probably
worked her ass off to get where she is
this little well again Watch
State University and lives in a two
million dollar home in the neighborhood
of and she was named
again I can't emphasize enough because
we blurred it this is street view of her
house yeah
in the specific neighborhood um
what were you thinking man and she was
named one of the most watchable young
leaders in 2017 by a trade publication
we also now know that she was given a
ticket by the police for the disturbance
she calls but she refused to sign it and
was never arrested
so that's Dylan page who in my opinion
all right we should say uh he did uh
delete this right right he deleted it I
think it got millions of views though
right probably probably when I watched
it it had at some point he must have
gotten the feedback that bro what the
are you doing and yeah yeah one
like I love how I get banned on Tick
Tock all the time I guarantee nothing
happened to him nah yeah no one
I I don't know if this is illegal I
don't know if she can sue him but she
should so and it should be I don't think
it is I I bet on a technicality he's
gonna not get legal troubles because
he's not the one that originally put out
the article yeah and I mean it's for the
most part that's probably all
information that you can obtain publicly
yeah I mean legal is different from
moral or well nobody knew her name right
just why are you doing this I think she
could sue him she's consulted with
lawyers she is good girl if you're
watching the Sue this little
piece of I wonder if she's uh gonna
try to sue the people on the plane who
posted it too nah really why would they
do wrong
exploited her like meltdown and caused
the world to know her I don't know I I
wouldn't blame it I don't think you can
yeah yeah you can sue somebody for
anything but
I don't think they did anything I
personally don't think they did anything
I mean that's what happens you go out
I don't know if it's considered public
space on an airplane let's go
it's kind of a common public space yeah
I don't know filming people is generally
fine
that being said
you know it's it's crazy because she's
like wow a month I think I'm gonna be
okay and then this little piece
of
work phone number address neighborhood
City County name
it's disgusting man
really pissed me off
uh there is no uh policy against filming
inside an aircraft so totally totally uh
legal
what they did filming
um
yeah I don't know I'm assuming his
comments section must have been a
yeah for him it was bad on that video I
remember because I saved this video
probably two weeks ago and then I forgot
about it until her apology good job dude
catching that yeah
glad I did I mean he hasn't he hasn't
said anything has apologized to anyone
so here now this poor woman after having
her life ruined by this guy and also
putting her life in danger frankly
um
was forced to give an apology for what I
still don't know but here it is she said
people were sorting through her mail
are you kidding me I'm not
surprised dude he does not get less than
five million views on his videos so
there's bound to be crazies in that five
million
it's up so here she is a this
came out when God yesterday yeah so here
she is and looking boss she's looking
like boss girl is literally look at
that low Pony
hi everyone it's me
Tiffany Gomez probably better known as
the hi everyone it's me Tiffany Gomez at
one two three
this kid Lane
crazy plain lady
which is completely warranted
as you know I
do but I do finally feel that it's time
first and foremost I want to
take full accountability for my actions
they were completely unacceptable
distressed or not I should have been I
should have been in control of my
emotions and
that was not the case
my use of profanity was completely
unnecessary
and I want to apologize to everyone on
that plane especially those that had
children aboard
can imagine going through that I mean
that's fair you know apologize to the
kids for profanity sure you get that and
trying to explain to your kid what in
the world
we all have her thank you
bad moments
um some far worse than others and mine
happened to be caught on camera for the
whole world to see multiple times
okay
sorry trying not to sound like me you're
okay girl
be strong yeah
yes
well it has been really comical for
everyone and I have highly enjoyed so
many of the memes
on the flip side it is very invasive and
unkind
and I don't know what I would do without
the love and support of my friends and
family they are loyal to a fault and I
don't know what I did to deserve them
um
sorry y'all
I hope that I can use this experience
and do a little bit of good in the world
and that is what I intend to do
I hope that you guys can accept my
apology and I can begin to move on with
my life I do not accept your apology I'm
coming to your house just kidding I'm
not and nobody should
right Dan yeah no never of course
thank you
Tiffany Gomez join me on my journey of
promoting positive mental health and
standing up against cyber bullying I'm
with you actually
and that seems like you know a girl
who's basically had her life turned
upside down ruined probably and uh
you know all for probably I don't know
exactly what happened but all probably
for having a
condition that's fully out of our
control
you know
so I wanted to say that girl we are
stand with you Tiffany mm-hmm
and I would love to talk to her actually
I would love if she if you want to call
in Tiffany also have good lawyers if you
want to sue this little piece of
I'd love to be a part of that I
hate that Dylan God he sucks
what are you thinking dude
says did you know what she saw she has a
YouTube channel oh it's just this a
smooth comments I'm curious what the
reaction was comments off good call
smart smart
let's look at the uh quote tweets let's
see uh get it off the screen please
thank you
this guy says I want to spend the rest
of my life with her
this poor woman Hardly did anything
wrong and she didn't hurt anyone this
was totally unnecessary everyone already
kind of loves her there it is I like to
see that
oh wait hold on
okay this guy's a good point this is
fake the real Tiffany Gomez would never
apologize for calling out a
that is not real yo I miss the old
Tiffany and of course uh v z v bear
coming in with it's okay now show us
your feet
all right okay all right high level
discourse going on all across the uh
Spectrum there
but yeah I I saw this and I I had to
talk about it just because I was so
pissed at this dude man
yo it's still up on YouTube shorts it is
yeah send me that link yeah I just sent
it to you
what the okay it's down on Tick
Tock but not on YouTube okay girl wait
does that mean that
this one is uncensored take
pictures and stuff so if she contacts us
we can provide her the receipts because
the fact that this is still up
not good bro and this is the one that's
uncensored
holy Dylan you are going down for
this you little
okay listen
um
uh Selena Gomez no that wasn't her name
what was it what Tiffany Gomez Tiffany
if you're if you happen to see this this
video of you is still up on YouTube
shorts we are downloading it we are
saving the receipts if you need it for
your lawsuit contact us
because he has not remedied the
situation let me look at the comments
dude you just told everyone her life
story you got her social security bro
you seem to have everything else why are
we doxing this lady dang the internet is
crazy so now we're exposing the private
life of someone who is most likely
having a mental episode damn what a
world no hate but why the are you
giving out information like she's
committed a crime
oh here's one from six minutes ago Papa
blessed with peace and love guys don't
okay that's a bad
so it's interesting that literally
everyone understands how up it is
that's why it's so so confused except
him except him apparently yeah
do you got
[Music]
this is a serious message to all victims
of goblin mode I would like to issue an
apology thank you thank you
saying it's
nice good job that was a good one that
was a good one and that was quick that
was right
I had said that in our WhatsApp group
and I remember Dan said do not say that
on the air yep and then I said it then I
hit the button
[Applause]
I'm proud of you that was beautiful you
don't get a sound bite clap for that you
get a real clap for that yeah I really
do want to say it because it is funny go
ahead what were you saying uh I don't
remember
people are saying it's still up on Tick
Tock I think you're talking about the
original video where she where he first
covered the plane thing I don't think
it's uh the follow-up with the with the
dog saying isn't there can you be sure
I'm looking over and over so if someone
has to link it but I'm also scrolling
through and I don't see it yeah I don't
think it's it's the original plane
coverage
dude you need to like do something about
this bro you need to accept some
accountability here and try to do
something
this is like keemstar level well how
does this compare to keemstar accusing
the wrong person of being a pedo
[Music]
apples and oranges yeah right um oranges
we have a uh Dr James weiner in the uh
Lobby stand saved by the wiener just so
you know would you like to speak to him
always okay I'll bring him in let me
check in with Jamie Lee real fast guys
uh James weiner Dr James weiner can you
pull up that dentist review I saw on the
subreddit there was do you know what I'm
talking about yeah linking that James
you've been through some man what's
going on your hair is looking
all crazy in your dome-ish super shiny
oh he can't hear me yet
nope
he's working on it audio audio
where he's gonna switch glasses when he
knows his own just watch he doesn't know
we can see him yet does he uh he's
probably no he should he's seeing the
return feed oh he should hear us now
hello Jimmy Jimbo oh nope it's back to
connecting dude watch him Shane shots
just so fast when he realizes those
glasses are pretty Jimmy Jimbo James
weiner you make yo Jimmy you've been
through something your hair and your
Dome is look your dome's looking super
shiny your hair's kind of off
that's the hairline snacks robotic hair
transplants coming up next right now
we're working on the face first I like
it I saw you got you actually got some
uh some some work cosmetic work done on
your face
yes and I wanted to thank Andrea Conway
and the team at the sarokkin plastic
surgery in Cherry Hill Andrea is a true
artist and uh absolutely talented at her
job and if you're out there Andrea uh
great job and I love you and eat sending
Ethan and Zach in in about a month
yeah I mean the before and afters are
frankly really impressive I think I
think you look great but I have some
questions
yes in the before you have the hairline
makeup on
on the after say it again yeah on the
before picture you'll have the hairline
makeup on
but but on the after you don't have the
no it happened to be a day when I when I
got my hair done before I went over that
was just by an accident oh okay where I
had my hair done that day and then I
think the second time I just was regular
so that here probably looked up the one
day and not the other
but I think it looks better without if
I'm just being honest because the after
you look so natural you look so good
do you think she did a good job I think
she did nice I got a lot of compliments
from it
let's see what is this one this is you
posted this one
I posted two images and I and Zach Zach
mentioned it so I sent him this the
images the other Andreas I have that
question for you Jimmy
I have a question if you look at if you
look at her before
and look at your before it looks like
you edited your before image
[Laughter]
somebody airbrushed your before
could have been Mason because Mason was
running this today
so I'm working all day and then you text
me an hour ago so I talked to Mason I
said Mason they want me to go on so he
sent me these back so Mason may have
been a little a little guilty here I may
have to handle Mason so well well no he
did be I mean I don't know why I mean
listen they're to the before there's
nothing to be ashamed of you're you're
gorgeous now do you think I got a shot
now
oh yeah okay just double you always had
a shot Jimmy uh I love you by the way we
shot a Botox
I owe you so much job what do you say I
missed it nothing good I said a shot of
Botox
say I I owe you so much
somebody nice and I love you what else
can I do well I love you too and I
thought it was important for Howie to
respect the uh greats in his field even
if he hasn't heard of them he he
mentioned the comedian they threw the
tomatoes out I do have a name and you
were nice enough to let them know you
know what I mean yeah
but uh anyway so you didn't know about
this you didn't know about the before
airbrushing
now Mason sent that back to me you
didn't ask Mason to do that
no Mason had the images and and when I
told him you want me to go on he says
you better you better put the images up
and he sent him back can I get mate can
you call can you put Mason on a
three-way so I can confirm that
I can't because I'm on the phone with
you and I'm on a zoom
right now talking to you and uh I can't
do that right now right sure
but um anyway what did you guys you guys
do you think they did a nice job so I
wanted that well the other thing I
wanted to ask you is that did you know
that she was doing a sponsored post with
this that's how we saw it she's paying
for this picture of you to be promoted
on Instagram to promote her business
so I know she asked me today permission
and she knows I'm a little bit of a
celebrity show I I didn't know she
sponsored it but she said to me would
you put the images up and I said I would
but I just didn't get a chance I was I
was slammed all day working and
um you know at the end when Zach just
texted me when I talked to Mason that's
when he sent them back and then when I
got to the diner I put them up I wasn't
going to put them up till tonight but
then you wanted me to come on so Jimmy
is it possible did you tell her how many
Instagram followers you have
yeah yeah 657 000. wow I'm getting big
I'm growing did you tell her that 98 of
them are fake
no I'm proud to say that I have 657 000
followers and I bought every one of them
it's 684
000. yeah
you
gained 35 000 followers in the past 24
hours I'm proud of myself dude wait
you're popping off dude you gained 35
000 followers in the last 24 hours what
happened you know why no why
because I'm popular
it's popularity kind of like Zach knows
at the Hollywood Bowl
right because most people with that many
followers would have a lot of Engagement
bring their posts
but let me put Let me pop over to yours
this one here has 300 likes
that's a fresh post though 22 minutes
ago no that's a fresh post that's not
fair yeah you're right it's fresh
so did you let me ask you this Jimmy did
you get a discount because of your
celebrity status
[Music]
thank you
you asked me that question I'm telling
you the truth
anyway
um so question for you East um just just
to confirm now that we're on am I good
because I booked my my vacation and am I
good for um Wednesday September 13th I
love it yeah if you want to come co-host
as James weiner yeah so I know you you
told me that and uh I I appreciate it
and I'll come and co-host like I did
before being just me that's fine Jimmy I
wanted to ask you though if they're
gonna use your image for promotions I
don't think they should get that right
for free like your celebrity status you
have a you have a right to publicity
Jimmy I don't think they should be able
to use that for free especially if you
didn't get a discount
right so I think I did mention to her
that I'm coming on your podcast and I
said Angie you know you did a really
nice job and I love you and I'm going to
plug you so I'm hoping I'm hoping that
you know that she's watching and Angie
if you are I love you and I'm hoping
that I get some love back from her boss
it's obviously up to Dr sarokkin but you
know I'm hoping that because I'm happy
with their service and I'm promoting
them that you know when I continue on
with them they help me out a little bit
on the back cam well you'll probably
yeah I'm sure they will listen you're
gonna go back there probably right
because you need Botox every like six
months or something
well she said fillers once a year and
the botox is every
single like an ongoing thing but not
that often because I'm learning and
getting educated about it as I go right
and you know as you get older look
things change and you know as you look
at yourself you're not as happy so I had
to kind of do something you know I'm
talking you've known me long enough so
well there's nothing wrong you look good
you look good but yeah the next time you
go in there let us know if she hooks you
up because
you know she's you get you can't let her
use your image like that
it's not right I'm going to politely uh
hope that uh they give me some love or
they have these a lasting uh serum
lotions maybe they'll give me a few of
them I just hope they do something right
yeah just something to be something for
the celebrities did you tell her you
performed in front of
how many people were at the 1600. did
you tell her you performed sixteen
hundred people alive everything and uh
she talked to Dr sarokkin and I got that
I got to know but uh Hey things change
in time when they realize you do nice
things for people and you and you help
them out and this is being on your
podcast and mentioning Andrea it's like
a huge thing for them yeah I agree with
this podcast yeah exactly the least they
could do is hook you up Jimmy which one
is the Forum which one's the after not
to be rude
Dan help me where's Dan oh I'm here I
was obviously
Dan tell him the before us on the left
and The Afters on the right well it's
confusing because the last image the
before was on the left
that's right
I'm flip-flop I want the truth Dan no no
wait a minute did you
flip-floper hold on am I wrong
so the one with the Deep circles under
the eyes Ethan is the before and then
she did a really beautiful job with my
eyes these deep circles right here right
15 circles are going yeah okay so this
is before and this is after so here
here's where it's when it's mirrored for
him is why this is where it went crazy
is because
I guess you photoshopped the one on the
left so much
that it almost looks like you're worse
on the after because you want to show it
out like all your pores
Mason's ass out if he that image
up too much I genuinely didn't know
which was the before and after you look
beautiful oh you better him up
Jimmy poor Mason go easy on Mason does
good work for you I I genuinely okay so
the right one is the after okay that's
do you see how why I'm confused you see
my eyes better that's the after because
here it could just be Shadow I don't
know
no the my main problem Ethan was the
lines on the forehead and the circles
under the eyes and my neck but here you
might just Photoshop them all out
like your skin looks smooth as hell here
yeah well the one on the right is is the
after look in my eyes you don't see the
bags as bad right yeah no you look good
so let me ask the girls like Olivia and
and uh you know uh ab's girlfriend your
girl what do you guys do the results the
ladies I think you look beautiful me too
yeah it's really good you're glowing I
love you I love you
what do you think or live about the
robotic hair transplant next what do you
think kind of go here and put it put it
all in there what is that can I ask what
do you mean by robotic hair transplant
so I've been studying this day and what
they do is they take they have a robot
that takes a square off the back of your
your head and they take little tiny
plugs that have like three hairs and
then they draw here where they're going
to do it too and then they put needles
above it
plugs in and then it takes up to a year
to heal and then you actually have a
hairline forever
can I ask you have you ever no I've not
plastic surgeons do it around here I
think that would be awesome but have you
considered it and I'm not joking like a
hairpiece a hair system no because Jimmy
Jimmy I've seen what they do today and
it is really good Zach told me don't do
that I asked
is that right were they going to get
their hair from you have a do you have
enough hair on the back of your head in
the back they take it yeah they take
little little plugs they don't put them
two plugs together and then a girl puts
needles on your forehead and sticks them
in it's just a four-hour procedure but
you're numb you're numb Jimmy there's
just no offense there's just a lot of
surface area to cover real estate that's
where you you and Hill would come in to
kick out of the money right right you
need me to donate some of my hair to you
because it's a lot of hair
okay we can talk about that off uh see
what you'll do for me I'm messing with
you tell that plastic surgeon to get you
a to pay you that'll be your half from
my what would you recommend I talk to
Andrea and ask for a free service or a
discount listen at your level
how much was it pretty hot how much was
the procedure
you want me to be honest yeah
well if you want my advice
the first the first time I went the
microneed only was about 2300 I I did
two of them and up two more to go and
the first time was five in the second
time too so I'm in all together almost
10 with micro needling and filler and
Botox which I think's a lot so but I
mean like honestly what isn't it what is
what isn't a lot today if you want
things done I'm a business guy you're a
business guy you know you have to pay
yes so if you want my opinion if you
genuinely want my opinion I mean ten
thousand dollars a lot of money but I do
think because of your celebrity status
you guys could I don't think you should
pay them a dime and then you can work
out some kind of agreement where you're
like in
in um exchange I'll do these posts for
you I'll mention you on the H3 podcast
and that's fine you can come here and
plug I think it's great
and all this stuff so you're the plug
that Dre's getting now I mean like I
told her how big you are and she's so
happy and she loves me and I I love Dre
and and her boss is a good guy and I'm
hoping they do something for me listen
the cost the the cost of this level of
shout out on this level of show Jimmy
Way Beyond ten thousand Way Beyond
people in my ear right now listening to
this and they know they're getting
phenomenal promotion on this phenomenal
phenomenal because I'm a happy customer
the results speak for themselves
do you think Harry Mandel and I together
should do a robotic airplane strand
actually apparently I asked Howie he's
not bald he just shaves it because it
feels cleaner
ah
what do you think about that by the way
I had to just pay you a company
chemist and just the way you two are
like you and me phenomenal podcasts
really oh thank you Jimmy I appreciate
that here I have another idea you can
offer to your uh
you're a cosmetic lady you have you
gained 35 000 followers a day you tell
her Jimmy you can do the same for her
I probably could I mean I put the post
up it had a name on it and I tagged her
no you should certainly good the
question right now I just put it up like
a half hour ago
the question is would the cost of buying
her a ton of followers
right yeah 35
000 from yesterday really impressive
numbers right Danny been through a text
he couldn't believe it thank you Dan for
the support anytime buddy never bought a
follower is that a is that a Bedminster
shirt that you're wearing by the way
that is my trumpet Mr shirt Dan you're
very observant yeah I was just noticing
that I thought it said Trump on the
Trump Bedminster yeah my wife's family
right your member that's right he's
wearing a trump shirt or he's a he's
like a the member of Mar-A-Lago or
whatever
let me see Trump
I can't read it uh what is Trump bed
Mister
there's a golf course in uh it's a
country club a very exclusive Country
Club do you want me to cut that part out
or leave it in
doesn't matter whatever whatever you
want to do he was extremely wet all
right Jimmy I just wanted to check in on
you I want to congratulate you on the um
the fantastic job
and I hope that you know in the future
you can leverage your celebrity status
for some freebies because that's what
it's all about
I I totally
[Applause]
totally share with you and she always
said this uh no matter what you do for
people there's always going to be people
that reciprocate and people that don't
and my wife always said rely on yourself
and she always said never expect things
from people but be happy if they do and
My Philosophy as I got older is
different and I'm blessed to have money
and be married to Lynn and I look at
things differently than I did when I was
young but by the way exactly what you
said is true but not all people are like
that I would say some more some more I'm
just being honest what happens you just
swipe something off the screen
me yeah
no that's how you do like this oh yeah
because I have to swipe up because the
people are like
you can't see them instantly got 15. you
get a notification
yeah there's a load coming in so hold on
do you get a notification for every new
follower or every new comment I don't
know they just keep coming but I do want
to answer the question this is something
that I wanted to answer and um maybe you
Ethan I I wanted to show my love to you
guys and take you down to Craig's one
night I have a huge vibe there with the
owner now even and and Patty and they
love me and I I wanted to do something
one night I'm in town next month they
got the best chicken parm and I and I um
and if you guys want to even go down to
pinks we're doing our official shoot uh
Saturday September 16th uh and and we're
gonna be down at pinks and if anybody
wants to come down at two o'clock
with the pinks people yeah this is this
is the same they have a picture on the
wall legitimately event because yes
Ethan I have two now two pictures two oh
that's amazing Mr Pink loves me yeah
pick your flavor we should throw you a
party over there maybe a collab that
would be kind of foreign
we should broadcast from down there
Saturday for an hour does he give you
does he give you free hot dogs Jimmy
please tell me he gets free hot dogs at
least hear me no he had to pay last time
we were there
he looks so happy that Botox is working
he looks so hot he's still in the call
so I think he his phone maybe uh maybe
he got a a phone call or a big follow
dump it just happened I appreciate his
dedication to keeping up the appearances
that he has never bought a father yeah
keep coming it's never happened
just gra growing organically it's
organic organic Senator Ghana yeah he
gets more followers per day on Instagram
that any of his videos have on his
YouTube channel over the past years I
think
is he still on the call
no he just hungry all right I wanted I
had a few more questions for him but you
know yeah we wanted to ask him about the
uh the review too right
[Music]
I'll ask that's a good question
all right standby he always has funny
Jimmy Jimmy
who's that who's that who's that Mason
oh my God who is that Jimmy tell me
that's Mason
who the is that
I've never seen him
this is a news Ethan I got caught off by
accident Jimmy who is that who is that
so I'm prankster is around and I
keep hitting Decline and I I think I hit
the wrong button to knock you out yes I
apologize that's Lee well he's a big H3
fan come over Lee say hi to Ethan he's
one of my friends from the dot he's a
manager at least say hi hey oh he works
there
yeah but he's like a huge H3 fan and
he's my buddy huge Jersey Outlaw Jersey
Outlaws man so wait you called on him to
come fix your phone
yeah I love that he's awesome
listening yeah remember with your dad
you know how bad I am with this no
you're good I appreciate you can
leverage the resources around you which
happen to be humans human resources for
a reason Jimmy do you get free dogs at
pinks
honestly he he comes out now and he um
he basically buys us lunch and there's
like 10 of us when we shoot oh that's
respect and you wouldn't believe my wife
happened to call me and I said Lynn I
want you to say hello to Mr Pink and Mr
Pink said when you come down I want you
to come down here and have Jimmy call me
I'm coming down and buying you lunch you
wouldn't meet he's more of an old school
nice person he is a classy guy what a
Class Act did you get the cheat did did
he buy you chili cheese fries too
he says uh to the girl bring more onion
rings I go Mr Pig we gotta he came out
with the Jersey Outlaw Dog
let's go nice so you get some respect if
you guys want to go down one day or come
Saturday on the 16th we're doing the
shoot Saturday the 16th just come down
and I would love to take you a couple of
you guys down to Craig's and the vibe
there is unbelievable it's a celebrity
spot and um
I want to read you one more thing here
um yeah uh where's that review guys is
it in I got buried a little bit it's in
Discord yeah so okay this was posted to
our subreddit
and I I apologize if this this is
probably a really old one oh yeah it's
from 2013. it's from goddamn 10 years
ago
yeah that's old but I I've I thought it
would only be right for you to have the
opportunity to respond to this person
okay they gave you a rating
on I don't know like rape my doctor I'm
assuming some kind of website like this
so they said I'll read it to you I have
to say I was quite disappointed by Dr
James weiner he was not very
knowledgeable to ask other Denmark in
the office questions repeatedly
review about my Dentistry hold on he
says he seems very friendly but he says
offensive things and he does this to his
staff as well he would not take the time
to listen to my problem with that
already having one foot out the door
he also put his finger in my mouth
without wearing a glove
I would not recommend this dentist to
anyone so I I just thought it because it
was posted on their subreddit I thought
it would only be fair to give you a
chance to respond
reached out look you get when you have a
business you get people that like you
and people that don't like you and
you're not gonna win everybody over
right so obviously there's one guy we
didn't win over can I ask you is it true
that you put your finger in people's
mouth without a glove
absolutely not every every patient I
always wear glasses I believe you
yeah so you know you know me as Jimmy
Lee but you don't know me when I work in
my office and I'm serious professional
and kind and loving with people and I
have so many older patients that will
only see me that love me and they've
been coming for years because I'm a good
dentist when I'm serious and
professional I believe I mean listen
you wouldn't be as successful as you've
been and by the way I know James weiner
he's a great guy
and I love you and and I just I owe you
Ethan so much for being so kind to me
and believing in me because I'm a little
guy and when you made a little guy feel
a little important you put me on and I
pick up some fans and stuff it means a
lot to me because all I really ever
wanted to do in life was beloved and I I
didn't get that as a kid from my mom and
dad so I have to get that from the world
and you know you helped me to accomplish
that goal and I love you I don't I mean
that's just coming right from my heart I
mean it I'm not just making that up you
know I know and I love you too Jimmy I
genuinely I love your stay up I know as
I've grown with you they've a few didn't
like me to hopefully they like me now I
think they know where my heart is deep
down we all do you we love you dude I
mean I'll tell you what Jimmy the Tomato
incident will go down in history that's
one of the greatest H3 moments oh you
are so nice and listen
um if Zach wants to reach out
um the days off there the 12th to the
18th I'm seeing you the 13th if you guys
wanted we'll work it out would you and
Zach can work it out behind the scenes
but I just want to say thank you Jimmy
have a terrific lunch are you there by
yourself are you with somebody no I I
come and do Monday dinner alone I sit
with Lee sits with me and then I got to
do all my paperwork to Monday Tuesday or
my 14-hour work days they're the worst
days yeah put in the work Jimmy God
bless you I am I'm awesome but I'll see
you guys next month okay and you look
fantastic okay be well
oh I love you and Ethan and to everybody
there on the gang thanks for loving me
and having me on
bye girl
bye kids have a good day bye love you
love you buttercup my girl all right
love you honey love you love you honey
bunny bye-bye love you Dan bye bye love
you pumpkin see ya love you sugar plum
good to see you
we'll see you next time bye honey plummy
bye honey thanks thanks Jimbo
thank you bye bye-bye bye sweet boy I
love you bye boopy
I got my eye on you Zach oh my God
all right talk to you later sugar
adios
adios see ya alrighty have a good meal
take it easy just leave him on thanks
just leave him alone Brad say bye to my
girlfriend he won't he won't close up
you can mute it and let's see if he
points up or not
he's ordering right now sorry
I just want to see he can't hear us
right it's muted no he probably can he
mute us I don't want him to know where
he is sorry I just muted his side okay
I've muted ourselves okay yeah so I'm
really curious how long he leaves the
phone on but we can hear what's
happening on his side would you like to
yeah yeah he's ordering I want to hear
him ordering oh I don't know if I can
mute myself with that well let's just be
quiet we'll be quiet we'll whisper okay
all right it's open
I heard him ordering something but it
got quiet
I mean he is by himself is it frozen or
do it no but he's by himself yeah he
said he's having dinner he's buying oh
he's cute oh I hear something
okay uh we can just come back if you
notice anything we'll switch back to it
yeah okay just leave it open
someone said he's kind of slur
uh yeah leave it open for real I gotta
we gotta keep checking in throughout the
episode
yeah I'm just trying to say
Zach maybe turn down the bus the the
send the microphone send
so I can leave it open but he can't hear
us
here's this one right bus four it got
real quiet it's like a real nice
offensive guy by himself yeah
probably reading the news all the way
down there you go
check check check check okay yeah all
right he can't hear us anymore nice
so somebody keep an eye on the feed yeah
okay we'll continue but if anything
happens just you know bring it back yeah
thank you that's Jimmy Lee everybody
he's like you know what I mean it's like
it's a whole roller coaster with Jimmy
you love him he really is a great guy
deep down he really is oh people are
saying this is mean what I'm people are
saying we're being mean to him by doing
this hell no this is the magic of Jimmy
Lee I just I'm putting it out there guys
if this is mean this is then then did
Jimmy Lee should ever be on the show
this is the magic
this ain't right what are you guys
talking about this is the magic right
here this is why you're watching
it's not legal what are you saying
lawyers in the chat telling us
this we're breaking the law okay here we
go now we got some action
I to tell you the truth he did say he's
there by himself to do paperwork I I
don't think we're going to get that much
out of this well it yeah if he's just
something revealing I can button
right we have the bottom we won't do it
let's do a poll is this mean or not mean
if enough people say it's mean I
personally disagree I get them but we
can we can
spying is kind of a Vic wow I didn't
expect this to be so polarizing
that's the thing that's the thing we can
button out anything that's
too private right yeah it's it's really
not that bad with the bottom
no
I'm not trying I'm not trying to spy on
him in the sense that I want to find
some secret info just I just want to see
him like put food in his mouth or
something yeah funny
it's a soft box oh my God elder abuse
okay it is elder abuse let me do that
my whole relationship with them is elder
abuse frankly
I just end it he all you all ruined in
the we got about a third of the audience
that uh
thinks it's too mean the 62 all right we
Jimmy we were not being enough we we we
respect our private camera my friend
he's on to us he knows I think he knows
you think so well he turned off the
camera oh but he's still there all right
let's hang up Jimmy we love you
uh take care Jimmy and we respect your
privacy too much
here's the thing anyone who knows the
full story arc of Jimmy Lee would never
feel bad for anything that's ever done
to him no exactly that's what this guy
has caused chaos turmoil and suffering
on the streets
and the stages all around the world and
me yeah right and and Zach but we love
him for it
All Right Moving On
Kimmy Lee everybody
there he is there he is folks
a great friend to the show in fact
right so
um moving on let's talk about Crowder
and then we'll talk about are you maybe
we'll do the Bobby thing so we don't run
out of time yeah I was just gonna say so
Bobby Okay so
Bob Bobby althoff
what is this comedian did I say her last
name right alfof
so Bobby altoff is a comedian uh she's
very funny in fact I'm just gonna toot
my own horn here I've been following her
since even before all of her phenomenal
podcasts guests okay so I've been a fan
since before
uh it was cool really that's you did not
reveal this to us when we were talking
about it earlier I didn't know you I did
say that I thought I said mentioned that
I've been following her for a while you
know this yeah I knew about it okay I've
been following since like way back let's
see if you go back back back back when
she had a baby and she was doing all
kinds of she was doing the shtick with
her husband where like she hated the
husband and
I I thought it was funny she's got she's
a great thing right her whole
stick I guess and not to demean it by
calling it but she's very funny
um here's her and her husband
and as new parents nothing but love you
know what I mean for for the two of them
so she's been blowing up big time and I
first noticed this whole podcast
phenomenon when she did this podcast
with uh funny Marco
this is phenomenal have you all
seen this no I haven't God it's so funny
didn't know about any of this until this
whole like Drake thing went down so this
guy funny Marco who I discovered via
this and I now follow is another kind of
tick-tock comedian but their chemistry
is nuts dude and I'm sure that Drake saw
this and then reached out to her for the
interview but here's a clip oh you're
not my type what's your type uh people
that
I my type is just brothers a lot of
brothers a whole lot of wild ghetto
just booty titties
uh just somebody just patting ahead all
day
and just saying where's my baby daddy
where's my baby daddy oh you got me
up I'm about to bust all your
windows out you got it all twisted in
this go get my
gun before I beat your ass
and I cheat on her and then she just
like oh no the you didn't cheat on
me and she beat me up and then I'll be
in jail and I get out and I'll be like
yo like why you call the police on me
and she's just like
because you ain't and
that's when I'm just like yo yo yo lady
chill out I love you and we start
kissing I think she's like now go in
there and take care of your stepson
because he ain't really your son
and I'm like whoa I
like that I don't think you got that in
you at all you got spooky hearing it out
you know and that's just real life where
I come from a straight gutter just out
the wall blown
everything is just
just like a waterfall just keep dropping
and you don't even know who Tupac is
uh you're not my type well let me find
one where it's got more
of their what the more of their
back and forth hold on one sec here one
second
this was uh let's see this yeah
so then I thought you have really white
taste by the way
what do you thought they would be like
mine mine aren't really white no why is
it like yellow or some yeah mine
are yellow no you think mine mine are
you're not yellow yeah yours are really
white I just I was complimenting you and
you're taking it you said like like wow
your really white like like your
should not be that white you would
really like to be offended by everything
I say no if you look it back I think
that's you I was just caught off card
you smile oh wow your teeth are really
white and you did this because it's not
typical to have teeth that white
that's unusually why I do get them wind
better not be yes after all this you've
just do you whiten your teeth
do you whiten your teeth
do you whiten your teeth why are you not
answering me
wow
do you whiten your teeth
it takes 10 seconds yes or no I just
ripped them out the plastic they may
acting brand new
be happiness so anyway I don't know it's
all very very funny stuff like this and
so uh what the this one is 26
million super easy
oh like
easy to get along with
I mean however you want to take it you
said yeah
yeah I'm pretty easy
that's good me too
I have I feel like I need to start
having standards for myself
you don't have standards I dated a girl
in a wheelchair
no no but I'm telling you she walked out
my life still
[Laughter]
sorry to hear a lot
yeah
invited to you
roll out of your life oh she actually
walked out of my life
okay so I'm trying to figure out she
just blocked me after work
she blocked yeah so I don't know the
whole time if she was pretending because
I got a camera I heard just packing her
stuff up and putting it in the car
and I was blocked and I'm like oh no she
walking straight up right now no this is
really happy
how many flights of stairs does it take
to get up to your apartment
well I gotta have an apartment
can you open this for me
Charlie I'm stuck on the apartment well
I gotta have an apartment
we got houses
nice ones
would you say that you're easy so okay
very funny so after this
this was a huge viral from like all
these clips have so many views
and then all of a sudden she starts
posting pictures of her with Drake
and their start teasing
that she's doing an interview like this
with Drake
now she did the interview
it as we expected got a gajillion views
55 million did have 55 million views on
YouTube really I think it was total I
forget it was it was up there though it
was very high
very very high so it was you know a
viral just as we expected
uh and very funny I gotta say like if
Drake is doing PR right now that was a
really good move because I thought he
came off really likable and very funny
and I and I even hate to say this down
to earth yeah you know which is kind of
weird to say about a guy that lives in a
billion dollar house literally yeah he
calls himself champagne poppy yeah but
he he was really he was really funny I
gotta say it really uh
I went home and I put on some Drake oh
yeah
okay
Drake so
um
here's a re-upload of the video so
here's where the mystery comes in
yesterday was it
um either yesterday or the day before I
think they both unfollowed each other
and she erased all social posts with him
and erased the YouTube video interview
both of them
had like a straight up social media
breakup
how weird is that right and obviously my
first thought was like it's probably
publicity right but um we're gonna we're
gonna go over that here's a re-upload of
the episode just give you an idea
she flew out to uh his house in Canada
marking
offers in Memphis because I thought she
said something like okay it was in
Memphis
you like that a song you didn't think I
knew about that
we start
when do we start yeah no yeah okay hi
guys welcome to the really good podcast
um with your host Bobby altoff today I'm
here with
can you introduce yourself
that's awesome Drake
that's my name
that is my middle name that's not your
real name that's my government name
middle name
why would you go by that what's your
first name my first name is Aubry
um
let's see where you go with yeah yeah
but
yeah I think my mom named me after a
lawyer which always kind of like
rubbed me the wrong way because like I
don't know why would you just name me
after like a
a random lawyer unless like there was
something else going on you know I was
named after a cheerleader my dad thought
was hot really
yeah Bobby yeah it's an older name my
dad's old
okay but like
for a fact like you've seen the girl or
no you showed me no he showed me again
it's just
it's pushing the boundaries on something
that
could be misinterpreted like on my end
just say it
during your show but then people are
gonna be like
so I
without watching too much of this here
it's basically they have a really good
report very funny yeah
I wish I could show you the the clips on
Tick Tock that grab the best moments but
I don't know are there any up Olivia was
telling me there was shorts up is that
so not on her Tick Tock they're taken
down
or on YouTube yeah charts
I didn't do that
so um
here
the next day or yesterday they started
racing the and I'm wondering
also by the way she did a uh
she did an episode three months ago when
she started this podcast her first guest
was Colleen Ballinger
that's so bizarre because she's not
she's now unlisted by the way yeah I
wonder if Colleen asked her to take it
down or if she took it down during this
hell no she took that down yeah
Colleen
right
haven't heard about Colleen in a minute
I guess she's just laying low huh smart
joke
here is a short this one's a little
easier to take in other questions do you
have any other questions not really not
really it's probably probably best you
just get out of home to
be tomorrow at home
you're gonna buy me a flight home
I can do that
it's the least I could do
can it be non-stop Non-Stop
was that like good so anyway whatever so
what is going on here I'm very curious
what y'all think is is it possible
sure they did an interview with her
let's see when I started my podcast in
April I wanted to do interviews with
celebrities but I didn't know how I was
going to get there it's really hard to
get my guests so I made a video on Tick
Tock saying I would give 300 to any
person who's successfully connected me
with a celebrity
kind of interesting really oh that's
that is a good move again just a little
Headhunter thing selling out their their
famous friends for 300 bucks I I got the
same standing offer it 300 to
anyone that could get me a drink let's
see who do we want Barack Obama 300 for
Brock
[Music]
and too and too
we could have a banger interview with
Brock what about Trump 300 bucks for
Trump easy
yeah standing off for great
um
so uh Rick Glassman the comedian was the
first person I was able to interview
because somebody tagged him and he was
like okay I'll do it and I sent her 300
bucks and did the episode with Rick
there you go girl
then I got a random comment on Tick Tock
asking if I heard of funny Marco a
comedian also known for his dry
interview style took a screenshot of the
comment posted on my Instagram stories
and then tagged him saying Marco if you
want to make this girl 300 DME he had
over 4 million followers at the time and
I only had 500 000. I was like hey uh
he's not going to see this but he
replied like a second later so I sent
the girl 300. he came on the podcast
our video together got so many views and
Drake liked it and then he followed me
this is dude the the
the way that these podcasts hit I almost
haven't seen anything like it before
podcasts are boring man they're hard to
like get people to watch yeah you know
be like hey check out this
awesome podcast I mean how many people
are just gonna watch that and then go
watch the podcast and yeah most podcasts
you need like prior prior like lore not
ours you can just hop in every moment
there's no back there's no inner jokes
yeah yeah we I intentionally craft it so
that anybody could hop in at any time
and understand everything we're talking
about yeah I thought she had like a like
a little bit of an industry plan vibe to
her at first but hearing what you just
said that she kind of head hunted and
stuff like that kind of makes makes
sense I guess well Dan had an industry
plant Theory which I'm curious about but
I mean listen it went up it went a
little too easy don't you think Marco
and then Marco to Drake it's a big leap
from Marco to like the most famous
person in the world yeah
Cuban oh and then Mark Cuban came on
because I well what I yeah Mark Cuban uh
let me go to our YouTube channel and see
all the famous people she's had on now I
feel like Mark Cuban will be probably
saw something in her like when when he
uh he wanted to be after Drake I feel
like everybody saw these funny Marco
ones and was like I can do that yeah you
know right
um I decided to just go for it she said
and shoot my shot I DM Drake and asked
if you want to be on my podcast he said
yes
he sent me his touring schedule and I
knew that I need to make it happen fast
so I me and my friend flew to Memphis
two days after the original DM was set
to record the episode I mean listen
Drake has done stuff with this before he
played uh he played with Ninja that's
what catapult did him yeah that's true
he's all he's also played on Twitch with
other people also he just casually plays
gambles you know on a steak.com Just For
the Love of the Game yeah yeah not not a
sponsorship at all definitely not
um so let me see now Dan you had an
industry plant Theory and I know that's
like a running joke
what is an industry plan can you tell me
that I don't even know what that means
well I think usually you hear it in
relation to the music industry where an
artist will suddenly blow up and just as
getting promoted everywhere and
um the idea is that
they have the full support of major
label but they are trying to make their
explosion and viralities seem organic so
how do they find this girl they just
someone found this girl and says you're
going to be famous like what I mean
here's the thing she so she had a huge
following on Tick Tock prior to any of
this podcast stuff of just being like
one of those mom tick-tockers or
whatever well her Persona is the same as
you see on the podcast she just did it
with like her husband
right so I'm not necessarily saying that
her entire career is set up
um however the sudden just surge in uh
popularity and just being all over
social media and everything and pretty
much immediately being able to disappear
huge guests
um not just Drake I mean the Mark Cuban
one really like raised an eyebrow for me
too it's like Mark Cuban isn't just
going on random new podcasts on a
regular basis that's a good point I
haven't watched The Mark Cuban one yeah
but look I mean look she hasn't done
that many episodes one was Colleen which
she acts ripped to the goat
I think I read earlier that uh that
episode was released the week that her
controversy started so awesome good
timing so then funny Marco this one went
massive on Tick Tock I mean it has 3.4
million on YouTube which is a lot for a
podcast especially a channel that like
just got made
then from that she talks about
Armani white I don't know who that is
I'm assuming it's a musician
then little yachty then Mark Cuban
or Drake was before Mark Cuban I think
but she removed the episode I
think the trick was after
but it was like really I um and then and
then she she just did Tyga
right
crazy
so what so what's your theory behind the
industry planting you said you read
something I didn't I don't necessarily
have a theory I I just I
well so first of all one of the main
things that you'll see and I'm seeing in
our chat right now is that uh oh she's
got the same management
as you know Drake or whatever okay so
from she she's managed by WME now Ethan
you can speak on this but that doesn't
mean as much as people probably think so
when I heard that as someone who's even
worked with them on the uh influencer
front yeah the influencer WME is like
not even in the same building like this
is like a joke dude the Indus the the in
the influencer side they literally just
email anyone with 50 000 views and try
to just parasite any money off them
um I highly doubt
that
WME representing Drake has almost
nothing to do with WME representing her
although I mean if she blew up this big
I can see them making a connection there
you know well yeah potentially but the
weird thing was like I I couldn't find
I was Googling around before the show
trying to find exactly when she started
getting represented by WME because there
are several articles out there in the
last week or so saying that she just got
representation from them after the Drake
interview girl you should be careful
about that because you go big all of a
sudden you have all these people
reaching out to you and you're like oh
WME that sounds great no they're
horrible but these articles I I could
not find a Solid Source on that claim
and they weren't necessarily on it was
like I think I saw one that was like
dexarto which you know no shade did
dexerto but not necessarily
Pulitzer stuff here you know what I mean
um but I tried to find some sort of
announcement because usually when WME
signs a big influencer or new Talent or
something they'll put out
PR about it yeah you know what I mean
they'll announce it or they'll put
something in the trades like just being
with wnb sort of any official
information so I I don't know where
they're getting
this info that she was just signed to
WME
but even if she is that seems kind of uh
light
for industry plant
seems to me like I mean two points a
little bit more towards that but what
does that happen I don't even know what
that means it's like she's a famous sort
of tacit support of the industry I don't
know she makes good content algorithms
and everything without you know
subtly try to make it seem I'm I'm team
Bobby I think she did this
and the rise is insane I I agree but
like
I mean I don't think you I don't think
it I'm not trying to take any credit
away from her I think regardless she's
hilarious and I like these interviews so
it doesn't necessarily right it's a
great product everybody loves it I mean
you could tell from the funny Marco the
Drake they have like tens of millions of
views but okay
um is is Tyga enemies with Drake
somebody said in chat I'm not sure no I
was wondering if maybe like she's gonna
bring on someone that Drake has beef
with and like it's promo for it but um
no like I don't I don't think so
so what is going on here because none of
them said anything and they just erased
very strange
so my initial thought is it's got to be
it's got to be coordinated I can't
imagine a world where they actually had
a falling out how is that even possible
yeah it's like a huge dub for both of
them they're it couldn't possibly be a
the only thing is like start I mean
we're talking about it right it and it
got a big wave of Buzz and then that
starts to die off because the cycle
moves on as these things do and then
they pull something like this and all of
a sudden everybody's talking about it
again and looking for it maybe it goes
back up in a few days well I think they
if they're doing it on purpose it's got
to be in
preparation for something they're
planning
either another video together
where they have some backstory about how
they got in a fight and erased each
other from social media
the only serious thing I could see is
potentially
some kind of legal thing but that just
seems so dumb to me
or like maybe
she went to his show and he was
creepy maybe and forgot that she was
married wanted to hook up huh I don't
think so well here's like I don't think
she would probably respond so
like publicly because people are gonna
see that you aren't following you delete
all your and then why would Drake
erase her it's like so petty and weird
that's an interesting Theory I hadn't
thought about but here she she was just
at his show this was what Saturday
Saturday here's some here's what she
posted
uh uh which I guess is now erased right
oh I can't yeah I can't do that but
anyway imagine Drake's playing
yeah Drake
yeah that's what he sounds like
I Love Drake
so she she erased this
okay
what the it's pretty what the
I don't know
it does not make sense in my brain even
if it's like a public discount to delete
viral so counterintuitive because
that actually was still getting views
that was still it was such a fat
dub for both of them yeah so in my brain
it gotta be legal stuff that it wasn't
like an authorized interview with his
label or some and that would be
crazy if Drake couldn't like tell them
to off though
by the way I've seen her joking about
this industry plant thing I didn't know
that people were actually serious just
celebrating because the industry planted
me I mean I I've our shot seems very
divided on it what
I don't even get that I guess do a poll
I'm curious about the industry plant
Theory
I feel like industry planned is just
having a big team behind them like
having a good uh she's a plant dude
again it's just I had a following before
the the key aspect of it it can take a
few forms but yeah that people don't
necessarily catch on to the fact that
they're being heavily promoted they're
being groomed promoted
okay do a poll industry plan
probably is an industry plant
it's like Drake is
Petty like that I
um yeah
like I wouldn't put it past him to
reciprocate like in a nasty way well
remember that DMC sent fantano that
was yeah right
he doesn't play on Instagram in fact
this interview was so good I forgot that
he's such a petty and I was like
oh he's down to earth and cool right
douche me yeah is looking quite
divided here close to 50 50.
she's been on the internet so long and
she's been successful people like well
listen it
her initial success I think is almost
certainly organic I think the industry
plant thing is just for the podcast
specifically it's getting defensive set
up to be listen I'm not getting defense
for Bobby I just I just don't get it you
don't talk about Bobby what the
I'm under plant team by the way
I'm being paid to run defense for her
botanist
so if if this is actually a real beef
it's stunning it's unreal yeah but I
it's so crazy I really have a hard time
please interview Rich Lux rich is part
of the gang he's coming with us to
Disneyland for sure
mindana gonna hold hands and skip the
whole time they're gonna ride on Space
Mountain together that would be good
concert that is the queen
yes
so I see lots of people saying Drake is
a creep I'm not sure I don't know about
his whole lore you know I mean I know we
goofed on him for the Millie Bobby Brown
thing which was pretty weird so bad yeah
that was almost pretty bad so maybe he
tried to you think he maybe he tried to
have sex with her that would certainly
do it I think maybe
yeah Millie Bobby Brown Bobby altoff
dude oh yeah he just thought that
she was single and that she came to a
show and
like she could have just been like no
off I'm married like I feel like it
wouldn't have been that
serious attic right I I I I mean
again this is like crazy speculation but
I don't think he's a I don't think he
would I didn't want to say it it's so
absurd no do something no no no because
then she follow unfollows and then he
unfollows no gotta be it's Gotta Be
we're gonna have to check back in on
this in a week yeah because he did like
follow I spice then unfollow I spice and
then re-follow I spice like what was
that about he's it was about probably
thinking she was hot
but like
he does do that it was in the news that
is good to know such a weirdo
I mean we gonna keep an eye on this
because if they don't come out with like
some kind of planned thing in the next
week or two then this is serious this
actually is a real beef yeah which I
have to know what happened then I'm
defaulting to that Drake did something
weird and creepy
um my brain goes there
right yeah if it's not no all comes
razor to me is legal stuff
ruins it all
so um so if Occam's razor if we were to
follow the razor Don followed the
deleting
occamed razor tells me it's a fake it's
a good it's a
it's a planned I mean that was my
initial impression as well but right now
yeah I agree with the planned stick but
in if it's nothing changes in one week
it changes to him being weird I guess it
has to yeah because it wouldn't make
sense to remove it and then like prolong
it even longer it doesn't make any sense
for them for I I yeah the legal stuff
doesn't make sense with the unfollow
yeah also it's
coming back to the poll it's almost
exactly 50 50. I feel like this is the
most divided we never get pulled to this
club I can always lean one way or
another a little bit but
yeah I don't know
the people are torn and frankly I am too
that's why I was saying I don't
necessarily subscribe to the theory but
I
there are many elements of this that are
very strange someone says I think this
is a nothing Burger do you have you ever
watched the show before that's all we
talked about literally what we do
nothing I'm talking about it for an hour
you spent a week on xqc a guy eats his
toenails
oh my God Olivia I need to call you out
girl uh oh oh here we go
what oh you know what you know it's
coming it's like I do send me that post
I mean that's happening no what send me
that both I will you have to be the one
to send it really I mean because it's
your It's Your Thing listen it was on
the subreddit I mean yeah no the Reddit
really
Olivia Olivia let me put it this way hot
possibly soon to be boiling water
that was awesome Zach whoa let me
just say this what do we know is
Olivia's type
skinny crackheads that's dumb who said
that you said you did yeah I said that
she's into the skinny crackhead type
that looks like they could literally die
of starvation or overdose at any moment
sometimes
oh this went big on the subreddit it's
okay Olivia I get it look at this
thirst trapped xqc getting liked by
Olivia Lopez okay okay okay I don't and
then wait that's not even the thirstiest
one look at this dude that's old it's
literally old news before it was before
the beef I know that you can't you can't
how old is it though I can look when he
posted that no I I know I know you're
not liking post beef yeah
sure what I mean he's a cute boy I don't
know what to say nothing say nothing
obviously I know more about him now and
I'm not necessarily
um the toenail thing super attracted to
him this but does the toenail thing do
anything to you
yeah yep but he's so hungry he doesn't
know what to eat
I love that
oh Noah toe now biting that man does
that on stream I mean I just can't get
over it that man breaks up with a
girlfriend on stream this is crazy I'm
sorry this is crazier than all that this
man's single look at this
look bro don't do it
don't do it
don't do it yeah
oh man
it's not worth it people are watching oh
cracker wait ah wait no no no it's a big
difference does he eat it or does he
just get it started he's not eating it
okay so what's the issue bro what he
just gets it started what's the issue
he's putting his toenail in his mouth
you mean what's the issue
do you do this
I can do it maybe I wish I could I
am that Pleasant oh man I mean I've done
it before when I was like 12. just to
see if I could
but not since
why are you doing this what the
this is your boy Olivia I knew nothing
about listen if you wanted a crackhead
you got a crackhead hey
only the top part oh you only got
the top part
no that's that's a big issue to me then
he ate it
[Applause]
bro
he if he just got it started I'm fine
eating yeah that's a crime bro I
didn't know he was doing that that's a
confession to make go ahead I had a
crush on a boy in college who didn't
have sheets on his bed oh my God that is
so gnarly
that's like grosser than that the answer
is yes
that is like the worst of the worst I've
grown up let me ask you this
were you ever did you guys did you hook
up with them on the bed with no sheets
no okay
I sat on it though
the bed with no sheets thing is so
gnarly yeah
um when I touch a mattress even my own
mattress without the sheet I feel so
nasty I'd like to die yeah big news oh
boy big news go ahead twist I did not
see coming I just shared with me
oh well we knew Love's a juicer
like in The Thirst straps though did he
like the shirtless one sure sure I think
it's hot
girlfriend he's a piece of
though
he is hot are you are you souring on the
xqc panda yeah well he's making it
really hard but yeah
the the being up to his
girlfriend that's like beyond
anything like that's really that's this
that's real life yeah everything yeah
did you just say he's making it really
hard
this man had no sheets what else did his
room look like
was it bad it wasn't good yeah yeah
men out there take notes sheets on the
bed sheets on the bed faux show
women pay attention to stuff like that
you know like biting your toenails
having sheets on the bed looking the
toenail afterwards not having not having
uh streak marks in your toilet bowl you
know small things it's just the little
stuff I had no idea do you have a um is
there one thing like a pet peeve when
you go to a boy's house where you're
like no one time I was hanging out with
a boy put on the milk boys oh I did not
hang out with him oh that's almost bad
as Jordan Peterson maybe even as bad uh
it was like he
loved them in a way that he was like
these are my guys and I was like oh I
gotta go I gotta go that's a problem
that's a big problem and it was like
post pandemic too so they were extra oh
wow that's a problem good for you girl
um what else is there to say about Bobby
and Drake
you just have to wait for more I don't
know
she said she also scrubbed a lot of her
old content with her daughter she said
in her interview she realized she didn't
want to involve her kids in her social
media so she's gone through scrubbing
gotta know
I gotta know you guys
she went back in the race 73 videos in
the last 30 days so this is part of a
broader
project
what is happening
gotta know their doings yeah no there's
there's a lot Brewing it here is it well
we'll see
keep our eyes on you guys what year is
it I think we follow each other maybe I
can message her
do you think she'd be a good podcast
guest
absolutely yeah she's funny she's very
funny let me reach out to her
um
as a long OG fan I'll tell her as a long
time fan
a real one she doesn't follow me
wow
maybe she unfollowed me I swear she
followed me
maybe part of cleaning house she's
undergoing a lot of changes right now
girl she unfollowed you I I could I
swore she followed me she might I don't
know she's going through a lot right now
she don't follow you the same day she
don't follow Drake that's important that
is that's special it's an interesting
point maybe she just unfollowed a bunch
of people no just casually I can't
follow Drake casually yeah that's a big
that's a choice I swear she followed me
Joyce Dan you are so on it I think she
made I think she may have big-timed me
damn you get in the bed with Drake do a
podcast all of a sudden well I'm too I'm
chop liver
I'm just kidding I don't know if she did
for sure
oh so mischievous
no idea what's going with the live views
have you seen it it goes it's at 44 000
it goes up to 54 000 and swinging by
like ten thousand every I think it's a
couple of minutes visual bug I see the
chart in the back end it's all steady
what is it at uh it's currently
the latest update says 44
395. okay that's what it's showing me
now
that's how I feel
so that's all I have to say about that
one
um there is another kind of a good news
thing here
good thing to end the show on as we come
to the bottom here
the state of Illinois
God bless them
has put together
the first ever child influencer law
hey this has been long time coming yeah
check this out Illinois has officially
passed the nation's first legislation
aimed at protecting child influencers
in a move Advocates say is long overdue
the bill was passed through Illinois
Senate unanimously
in March signed into law in August the
Illinois law will entitle influencers
under the age of 16 to a percent of
earnings based on how often they appear
on videos Vlogs or online content Ryan
just got paid
to consent how old is he now let's see
well he did probably don't live in
Illinois anyway and they'd move if they
did all right Ryan all right we're
moving out of state
why Daddy all my friends in life is here
well I'll tell you about it later
he's still got five years of good
earning yeah yeah
this seems to be a national level at a
certain point though right no there's
he's still out there doing it man
11. he's still up there holding major
numbers am I pushing it
like if I'm a six-year-old I'm not
looking to hear an 11 year old's opinion
on the latest toys you should I
pull it up let's see what they're doing
Ryan's toys review bro Ryan kind of saw
all these washed it kind of fell off oh
man wait seriously yeah he he's
not hitting anymore because these
channels they they do like Buy
it's all about bulk oh man you're right
I'm sorry Ryan well this one has 600
dude for a minute when they were going
big every video had like
100 million views sort by most popular
let's see it dude check the most popular
holy he's still doing good though he's
still doing good I mean shout out Ryan
popular goddamn two billion you don't
see that b very 1.1 billion 448 million
400 million this was like every video
his merchandise was crazy too he had
like deals with Walmart
wow I I think they must have made like
hundreds of millions I'm sorry but why
are they still making this kid work they
got to be multi 100 millionaire like
they're worth hundreds of millions and
why are they still making him do a fight
I guess he might like doing it that's it
that was just the only happy outcome if
he's not just like a child slave is that
he likes doing it but I'll be honest I
met his dad and although I don't know
him at all I had a very short
interaction with him and he seemed like
a nice normal guy take that for what you
will yeah that's what the hell is yeah
it doesn't really do much but it is what
it is who knows we'll we'll find out in
the uh in the Netflix documentary and
influencer children where are they now
good luck Ryan I hope you I hope you
have a good outcome
seems like a great kid
okay so anyway the money must be held in
a trust which the child can get access
to when they turn 18. currently there
are no laws of protect child influencers
how it was brought to the Senate 16 year
old Shreya nalamathu started thinking
about the lack of legal protection for
child influencers when she assigned an
independent study project in school her
advisor suggested she reach out to
legislators I was like I'm just going to
shoot my shot she said I don't really
know what I'm doing but we're gonna go
see where this ends up wow
she connected with Senator David Kohler
who went on to introduce legislation
the call for legislation has not only
sent around finances but also privacy
one of the examples the article gives is
of Cam 24 years old grew up on a social
media presence that he did not consent
to they say details of their life
including their first menstrual cycle
and photos of them in the hospital
following a car crash were posted to
their mother's 10 000 people Facebook
followers cam testified in support of
the bill which would allow children of
influencers to request the deletion of
content featuring them from any internet
platform or network that provided
compensation to the individual's parents
or parents in exchange for that content
Camp's testimony they said I was nine
years old
the intimate details of my first period
were shared online I plead with you to
please be the voice of this generation
of children because I know firsthand
what it's like to not have a choice when
a digital footprint you didn't create
follows you around your lesson the rest
of your life geez man yeah
that's really it's sad that her like to
have that
like the mom is like no
hey Mom can you erase the video about my
period
so I guess just for no for reference
this is almost identical to the Coogan
law for TV and film yeah it sounds it
sounds very sounds like it yeah yeah it
sounds like it and this is what I this
is what we've always been so long yeah
it just needs to be extended I mean just
make it a federal law dude yeah but this
is good this is the beginning yeah
absolutely I don't know if Congress is
is basically put uh able of passing
anything though
like unless it's like a writer on a huge
budget bill
this one seems pretty like
there's elements here
that I think do appeal
to both parties well even in this era of
everything being divisive I mean you
didn't they in Illinois it was unanimous
unanimous yeah yeah but I'll tell you
this Dan I mean this is like anti-big
Tech too you know what I mean well
listen I'd like to believe you but which
party's been trying to loosen child
labor laws of course yeah it does run
kind of counter to that no I I agree
it's an easy dub for everyone
but uh yeah child labor laws are trying
they're trying to loosen those up the
bill the Washington bill is stalled in
committee so there's another yeah with
no forward movement since since February
the Illinois legislation does not cover
privacy concerns or the right to be
delayed came hopes it causes a ripple
effect and the protection of child
influence shout out cam
the 16 year old or no yeah and 16 year
old Tria
who just randomly uh had a dream reached
out to a legislator 16 is the age of
consent that's pretty wild can't
actually might be an industry plan
keemstar now is not the time sounds
seems kind of unlikely right
some 16 year old just happens to reach
out all of a sudden it doesn't make
sense bad for plants you know who paid
her Ryan
it's Ryan behind us he's the Puppet
Master
we're all just toys in Ryan's Toy Box
you know
there it is
Ryan Ryan Ryan
um how long we've been going we've been
going for three hours 10 minutes and 28
seconds
goes by when we're having fun doesn't it
so much fun we have here
uh folks here at the H3 podcast
well I don't know what else we can do
with the limited amount of time we have
left Baldur's Gate Dan loving it still
loving it I'm on that act two now baby
I'm actually enjoying it a lot and I'm
and there's so much to do in act one I
don't even think I'm ever gonna make it
to act two ever
like I got to this part what do you like
what do you what are you doing right now
I got to the part where
you can cross over into act two but I
said no because I don't want to do that
yet okay
keep going I'll explain something about
that and then I move on and then I went
into the swamp
which turned into this whole big
yep
[Music]
and I'm just finished that okay so
the warning that you get
uh when you're leaving the initial area
it's a lie dude you can go back it made
it seem like that was like a point
knowing that you could not apparently
all there's like a couple
quests that uh that are no longer doable
if you move on to there but only like a
few and they're probably ones that
you've already done so well I'm not
gonna I'm not ready you're not ready I'm
not ready he's not ready too much left I
haven't done the goblin Camp yet bro
oh I think the goblin Camp is what ends
if you that that is the one that will uh
get close I need to do the goblin you
got to do the goblin Camp dude that's a
big deal I'm like super over leveled for
it because I think they're like level
two and I'm like almost level five like
I want a joke
what a joke
um a lot of people were are asking about
the Crowder thing
no we have to do it no no we can't why
I'll tell you why because it's like it's
gonna be like an hour yeah there's a lot
here oh no yeah let's just save it it's
fine
can I just watch this little time stamps
a little bit of a crime to not watch
this
with our boy on Thursday because this is
this is a prime crowd the thing
that she's gonna have already talked
about it uh is this gonna be old news by
Thursday no it's not old news by
Thursdays a few days from now you can't
and he doesn't have on Rubble yeah yeah
no let me just you know we have to do it
on Wednesday because I'm telling you
we'll be here for another hour let me
just show what he asked for
okay let's do the the clip yeah 8 45.
here we go
here we go no no no no no no no no this
isn't it
I'm telling you if you hit play right
now we're locked in
so let me uh let me get the the clip
that this came from Let's uh let's again
there have been since we've been gone
there you go rumor Mill's been
circulating I know a lot of you have
been asking me questions
um so I'm gonna try and address this I
guess as uh as tactfully as we can in
general if you send it to me I still
have time to bail send me the clip that
I'm looking for okay well you can just
say shut up but
um
this man is literally sitting there with
a gun on his like bro you're so insecure
Jesus man
uh there you go maybe found it thank you
here it is
watch this newly single Crowder is
begging his fans
to send in love applications that's
right I do not
I do not uh and I think it's important
to find something real
um it's something that I still believe
something that I that I want by the way
uh and um this is also uh why especially
in looking for something real we are now
going to announce the win a date with
Stephen Kreider sweepstakes win a day
in charge baby I feel like that's not
something you win that's like something
you know
it's foisted on you
contest
is tolerated lizzo's not busy to date
Steven at louder with crowder.com that's
date Steven at ladder with crowder.com
again looking for something real real
meaning first I was like oh he's doing
but then this man actually has an
email that he says and puts on on camera
this man is asking his fans to come let
him them
that's next level
sad pathetic and so inappropriate
by the way also it would be a shame if
people sent him
emails at date Stephen
louderwithcrowder.com who aren't
actually interested in him good luck of
a little prank I would just be looking
to like waste his time perhaps it would
be it would be so much of a shame if
people wasted his time and did that I I
wouldn't I wouldn't suggest anybody do
that
because that's that'd be rude
super rude
or wait I actually have an idea it
I'll tell you guys because they won't
know if it's us or not let's create a
fake profile
of like some of some random crazy
conservative girl who's like a hardcore
fan and some like super hot cowgirl type
you know
and try to bait him into responding and
like you're not even gonna know who it
is dude have you ever seen the movie
John Tucker Must Die that's basically
what they do is the guy cheats on three
girls and then they get a girl to have
him fall in love with her so that she
can break his heart I have not seen that
it's we're gonna do it to Crowder let's
do that you guys I'm serious like I feel
like we can craft this in a way that
he'll for sure
he'll for sure respond I think it'd be
awesome he's gonna need a bite of this
cowgirl
he knows it might be awesome but he's
still like oh I gotta take the chance
it's got to be that's what's awesome we
don't actually even have to do anything
now
any of them or maybe we will do it maybe
we will maybe we won't
and if it's not us it could be someone
else who's listening right now
date Stephen Crowder at louder Crowder
with louder with crowder.com we should
uh this man's been divorced for like one
month
and he's begging people to send him
tasteful erotica
we should send pearls up just in case
she doesn't send her own oh
mm-hmm
she's not high stat status enough I
can't we talk about that she's gonna
she's gonna have to settle for someone
like uh
I don't know
he wouldn't
even he's too high status for her or you
think he's he's not into ladies
who's a really nasty conservative who
might be up to her down to her standard
I have to think on that yeah there's
someone out there for you though pearly
girly pearly girly that's the beautiful
thing about love there's somebody for
everyone
um
we're gonna go pull like a mutant out
from the sewer for you to marry she's
like slower she's like I need someone
who's less valuable
I'm so invaluable I'm going to the Sewer
to marry a sewer person
like a conservative Ninja Turtle
maybe even an animal human it
doesn't even have to be human
because like what's the stat I guess
some animals probably have too high of a
status for her
not even like a really dope horse like a
kind of a like a pony
yeah some Ponies are darker animals
maybe elephants elephant too
intelligence
the ceremonies the death ceremony what
animal is the lowest enough status for
her
a rat
seems too obvious
dolphin the dolphin would definitely
drown no I'm sorry
Dolphins too high status the dolphin
would kill itself for sure they're too
smart
all right well I'm excited to talk about
this Crowder ship we'll have to do it on
Wednesday then because I can't wait till
Thursday I can't
all right all right I can't do it I
can't jerk off to this all right
yeah
Rudy
oh here's a man who's in her
stratosphere
throughout this has an option there's
the face of love for Pearl although to
be fair he might be too high status for
her too I mean well he's a sexual dance
not anymore I think they're right
they're right together it feels true
Pearl bring those tits right over here
what's oh I'll claim my tits
what a music expression
be so epic if he died in prison
love that for him
all right guys it's been a great Monday
hasn't it terrific weather
month
great Monday oh you said Monday sorry
it's really been a great month hasn't it
great beautiful weather a fantastic fun
episode we had thank you to everybody
who joined us
we had highs we had lows we had
everything in between it's been a
journey someone said Big Nick
come and see that too big Nick X Pearl
you should slide they definitely are
aligned like politically in
sociologically
she's not a virgin though
am I right wall breaker she born again
though
no
there's one thing that can't be born
again
yeah it's that see it's too gross
hanging to it that's it it's that uh p
word once it's been effed
right right that ain't being born again
you can born your spirit again but not
okay and big Nick knows got it
uh members I'll see you guys tomorrow at
12. thank you to our members I love you
all so much
consider becoming a member to join us
tomorrow
also as a member you get all kinds of
great benefits including my phone number
and all my emails
access to Discord chats polls Early
Access to Live show tickets
Sports the show
[Music]
alright guys love y'all thanks for being
here
see you next time
[Music]
love ya